[Music]
four four
[Applause]
emily and i uh uh just realized that
we're wearing the same clothes we were
last week
not me on the podcast i'm fully wearing
the same horse shirt i'm still in mine
and emily still dressed as like um
marcel marceau which is a very high brow
reference
for this podcast um but uh
we have christa stefano here today so
funny we had such a good time so cute
and
you guys are gonna love this episode
because i hardly get a word in edgewise
it's very refreshing i was refreshed i
only nerfed
her once only nerf darted me once um
benton
this is his second episode where he is
out
i was wearing this sweater to cover up
the fact that i'm wearing the same shirt
last week but i'm hot so now i'm gonna
take this off and you know what
i love that journey for you i'm green i
wear the same shirt
and she doesn't wash it yeah i don't i'm
not gonna it smells like a horse help
help kill the it's like a scratch and
sniff it
benton is still uh out he
had a procedure and i say we
call him to see if he's i believe it's
ending
now ish let's should we call him and see
because i think he's on a lot of
painkillers oh this will be a treat
oh benton you're on the pod are you are
you okay
yeah oh it looks great you look good bud
i look
i look like very cute do you want to
tell everyone what you are at the doctor
for
wait are you you're on drugs right wait
what drugs are you on before you
and can you get any extra is it legal
for me to record you while you're on
drugs this feels like a
uh yes they gave them to me in a little
cup when they were little
are they the ones you give me before i
go night night
no they were blue oh oh were they viagra
that's why i said the same joke but they
didn't like it
you're facetiming me the way my
four-year-old niece facetimes me which
is just your forehead he was
very very um skinny so i was offended
and then um wait you need to tell people
benton you need to tell people why
you're at the doctor
listen i told him i said i said i bet
you won phone king didn't you
he said no but i don't believe him
okay did anything else happen did you
meet any
other friends yeah amanda she was my
caretaker and she was nice
okay okay um is she available to care
take me
she's on a daily probably i'm sitting in
this room right now waiting on someone
to come pick me up
uh-huh do you hope someone shows up wait
is someone is someone opening you up
do you want us to send you an uber pool
no but noah's coming to get me
nova's coming to get you okay are you do
i need to text her make sure she gets
there
or if it knows where you are i sensed
her a secret message do you
do you do you want to see my my jar of
blood
you need to tell people yes i do
yes jar of blood yes please okay i had
them i had them record
some of it while i was actually
happening oh okay hot content alert i
don't know who thought of this i don't
know what stickel came up with it but i
i i'm a fan you're a fan
what are you gonna do with your new neck
um i'm gonna probably wear chokers
what about turtlenecks are those gonna
be a thing yeah i'm gonna wear i'm gonna
wear i'm gonna
very tiny turtleneck how about
see-through turtleneck
i'm gonna like you guys turtleneck vibes
but you yeah i wanna i would like a
clear plastic turtleneck
yeah um i'm actually just gonna wear
straws around my neck
just straws
choker spikes very very
definitely choker with spikes on it very
nancy from the craft
benton a hot giveaway oh my god if you
subscribe to youtube
you get some of benton's blood let's see
the jar
i have to wear this thing on my head for
two weeks
can we see can you let it out a little
more there you go
to hold the oh my gosh
ben you're like wait you look like a
penis no you look like a
bobsled
you look like you're on a bobsled team
benton for two weeks
well two days 48 hours and then i
supposed to wear as much as i can for
two weeks
should we be dazzling it with bat bat
bap on this side that would be fun fun
fun
oh they told me to wear they said they
said wear a black hoodie that you don't
care to ruin so i wore this one
wait what
your face is leaking he still hasn't
told everyone okay
okay well do you want to share what you
did
or why you were at the doctor you'll be
able to see you don't be like they if
they don't see then something's wrong
then you're going to get your money back
let's see the jars so i think you just
did a little neck sculpt i think that's
kind of what it's called
yeah they they sculpted my neck mm-hmm
okay it was light bulb okay
you just whispered into a microphone
benton i know
well we love you we just did uh we just
did a little open and we're just
uh fumbling through here i'm waiting for
the fury of youtube comments asking
where you are
well now they now surprised are you
what drugs did you get do you know what
the blue ones blue i know but are they
sending you home with any
asking for a friend they are sending me
home with some they're sending me home
with an antibody
oh cool we're just gonna be home with a
fancy ibuprofen oh that good okay okay
with it with this medicine that i'm only
supposed to take if i'm in real pain
i bring that one to the one that i take
daily
and and also neosporin oh that's i feel
like we have that
wait what is the one that is only in
real pain is it percocet
vicodin do we have do we have an opioid
crisis on our hands
it has a little bit of it in there but i
don't i've never taken
any kind of pain medication sorry me
neither
me neither i would 100 think i'm
addicted to it i would never
i would never take a drug to numb
the doctor said that he went to school
in canada and i
said yeah well my dad's a cripple
that is classic benton at first i was
like
i don't want to tell anybody what i had
done but let me tell you a secret
it's not anybody's business i can do
whatever i want that's true
i want to get a chin implant can you
take what was taken from
you and put it in emily's chair yeah i
have a weak chain but a lion's heart i
asked if i could
donate it but you can't you can't give
somebody up fat
why not where's the jar where's your jar
of blood so we can put it on ebay
yeah it's in another room where's your
jar of blood we i want to send it to
army hammer
it's not just blood it's also fat it's
really really good it would probably be
really delicious if you like put in a
pan first and you let it fry up you know
benton we're not gonna eat your neck
your loss they gave me a they gave me a
cliff bar
oh great well emily has a half one of
those in her purse you're a lucky dog
because
because i'm starting right now with
being you know healthy
oh sure okay yes yes yes i like that
that's good great all right well we love
you is there anything else you want to
say to the pod fans
yeah i want to say that we have new
merch coming out and you should like and
comment and subscribe
and that um
that everyone deserves to be happy
yeah i like this profound kill
could you take this daily this feels
like a good match for you
they gave me laughing gas too let me
tell you something that
was dope oh wait were you under
like did you go under anesthesia i know
oh i was awake in the video where
they're actually doing the procedure on
me that i had them film
i'm talking oh i was just doing a type
five
i hope you totally recorded a standard
secret i was telling them i was like you
should listen to the podcast
and i made them all subscribe on their
phones oh my god that is
true he's a company never not hustling
never that is called
it's called that's called always next
generation
a b c always be closing
all right well don't don't worry you're
allowed to touch your face shit
well i think my cheek that's fine
nothing happened there and can you sleep
uh on your back or you have to like
sleep like
upside down hanging like a bat i can
sleep however i want instead
it's not like they didn't put the fat
anywhere
there was 33 cc's
gallons no
i could hear it it sounded like this
that is disgusting i mean good for you
you guys don't you
who needs roman when you can just hear
sounds like that uh
from benton who needs ed medication that
sponsors our podcast when you can just
listen to those sounds
i am med medication
basically i just go right up to the
penis and i go
why is the feathers disappoint
[Laughter]
when that's sexy
can we fully get bent into drug
addiction whatever this drug is
can i i kind of want this to be a weekly
thing
i have an addiction i have to live for i
don't have addictive
me either these last two months have
been smooth sailing
well this is annoying what like i'm
finally off uh
weed edibles and drugs and now you're on
drugs it's like we're just
we're like ying and yang there will
always be a reason to tune in
there'll always be someone off the rails
on this podcast
you look like you're a full blonde right
now because your little
red riding hood cap is covering the rest
of your hair
honestly yeah i believe you will i it's
it's very um
betty davis oh in the in the dark ears
gray garden great gardens
oh it feels like um your neck is leaking
yeah that seems okay maybe don't worry
are you supposed to talk oh yeah are you
supposed to be talking oh what are you
doing
i'm allowed to talk life is normal can
you eat
uh-huh they gave me a gay dread oh well
lucky you
remember gatorade gum ew no
oh you couldn't chew gum i bet i'm gross
but it's like my neck is leaking i'm
like getting gum you guys are gross
he's trying to show us a jar of fat that
gatorade gums where we draw the line
um we uh we miss you we love you
do you need anything no you'll probably
go home and sleep right
yeah oh i'll probably start a project
oh there's a podcast you honestly
abandoned if you could bang out like 10
episodes of a podcast
right now on these drugs it will be the
biggest podcast on the planet
i do think we should do some episode of
the podcast where we all do different
drugs or shots or something oh i'd love
that we should do like one episodes of
shots one episode where we get stoned
one episode
do mushrooms
did you know did you know this is the
secret did you know
none of what you're saying is a secret
it's being broadcast inner like
nationally at the moment
yes our friends um do you know
that when they take fat out of your body
you can't get the fat back where they
took it out of
oh that's i did because a lot of people
take fat from their legs and put it in
their
butts but why would you want to take it
out and put it back in the same place
that's an indecisive person no no my
dumb ass was like
why i ever want a fat neck again oh
yeah and the answer is no you're gonna
put in the freezer like a wedding cake
and a year later take it out for the
anniversary
i actually put it in my cheeks but they
said no no your cheeks are nice
no no no no yeah don't go in a good way
oh my god his eyes
but you can take it out i know people
take it out of their thighs and put it
in their butts
and their chins emily i know we i
thought
is it fat i thought it was like a device
you put in your chin i don't
know but you can get fat there too or
i've told you this a hundred times sorry
do we have ample video of you under
anesthesia to share with the fans
oh we have a lot of graphic content not
suitable for work
okay okay good that's because i got
fully naked
um we got that only fans is gonna get
fired up
soon there's just an only fans where i
only have fat removed
there's probably a kink for that i mean
everyone's there's a kink for everything
i'm learning
can you see it or is it glaring for the
people on youtube um
this is just kind of also turned into a
weird like asmr tour dates
should i read them uh yeah try to read
my tour dates ben 10 let's see what you
got
um oh i can't see them
well i can't read wait hold on ready
okay do you see that
make it a little bigger wait um
that says april 15th or 17th
spokane washington
comedy pub thank you for more
information visit whitneycummings.com
okay thank you great oh that wasn't on
there he just said
oh she's like bitching my heart
why he's happy i know it's just like so
sweet oh
wait
i think we should end this podcast soon
because i need to head on over there
yeah and make sure he got home okay
that little jar of blue pills makes me
very nervous right
and jealous yeah michael jackson's
doctor's in jail right
just confirming he's doing next year
he's confirming he's not still on the
loose
doing procedures
okay i gotta check my workers comp
situation
yeah what's the disability class i know
you guys think that was a
funny call but i feel like uh an
accomplice should we call his mom
uh for sure uh and my lawyer um
so benton will be back next week irl uh
we are now going to shut up i thought
you said r.i.p and i was like no he's
fine
yes the way your brain turns harmless
things into catastrophes
is an art um krista stefano
you guys know him uh chrissy chaos
chrissy
chaos podcast hey babe podcast he used
to do history hyenas with janice pappas
which is on patreon he is on patreon
he's the best he's so fucking funny
and smart and charming and don't easy
his girlfriend i would not cross her i
mean cute like a brother
yeah platonic cute platonic um he's so
great
we did actually an outdoor show the
other day together in la
um and uh god he was fucking funny his
stand-up is so
funny even after a year of us not doing
stand-up we're all rusty yeah he got up
there i was like shit i better pull it
together yeah yeah
and uh he was just being so funny he
like he'll throw in these little asides
like he's doing these really smart
sort of bits about you know what culture
and and you know
and then he'll just throw in like i
don't really this made me laugh so hard
he was like i don't really have to i
don't really pick a side like with
politics i sort of agree with this
person and this person
i'm chrissy flip-flops it's such a
dumb like it just made me laugh so hard
for some reason then chrissy flip-flops
chrissy flip-flops coming right up uh
like subscribe
all the things i'm really embarrassed
about saying that like what am i
what am i a tic toc star like subscribe
smash the like button hit me in the
comments
down below i am so i was watching one of
these youtubers and they go like
in their stories they're like i just
posted an instagram go like it and
comment below like i just can't do that
go follow the at good for you podcast
i'm like you do what you want to do on
your time
but also like and subscribe i'm not
going to chase you
i'm not going to oh yeah no i am i will
that's what emily's
invention that's what i'm here for i'm
not desperate for attention i'm
desperate like and subscribe or not
frankly i'll be fine either way
but do i'm enough
tour dates whitneycomings.com uh you
guys can easily find these but every
time i talk about tour dates you're like
where's the tournaments we're so
confused like
it's confusing i'm waiting for there to
be a billboard in your town to tell like
whitneycomings.com we know where these
dates are you know her name
easy to find spokane washington april
15th to 17th san antonio texas that's
coming up april 22nd to 24th brea
california may 7th and 8th houston texas
may 13-15 dallas texas may 20th to 22.
alaska arizona arkansas no i'm not i
don't have dates there
you're going to confuse everybody sorry
you put it nerd
above about a between do you don't know
one state
what was it no what was the one about um
the uh above about because
after against among around at before
after that was a private school
education i have no idea we were talking
about
these are um no it's called tourette's
uh no what is the um
the thing about not um what are those
things at adjective no um um
prepositions i'm just googling grammar
what is grammar
what is grammar like did you mean betty
ford grammar
what is it uh it's a when something's on
top what does that mean
preposition on preposition the
preposition song i
didn't i'm not i don't know that one
well sing it and i'll shazam it
here we go did i get it even close to
right i can't believe this is a song
that you remember
966 000 views
finds out the direction this podcast is
going when he's not here he's going to
be livid i'm fired
here it is look behind below beneath the
side between before beyond by
in from off on over of attila colorado
connecticut
delaware florida um it's so weird how
that comes back so fast yeah but i get
mixed up in the middle yeah no yours
didn't really come back but
the first couple did um we love you guys
uh do not ride elephants
enjoy your life we love you i love doing
this podcast me too
uh okay uh whitneycummings.com we are
coming to a city near you
and you should know that spokane san
antonio april 22nd
20 to the 24th brea california may 17th
to
nope may 7th to 8th maybe loud shows and
go to the 17th if you guys actually uh
listened to this or have gotten this far
uh may 20th to 22nd i'm in dallas then
tempe i'm in tempe i'm in
um you're all over the place i know uh
tempe arizona baltimore magooby's
baltimore
rubies i love you guys uh text me eight
one eight two three nine seven five two
seven i'm doing i'm back to doing daily
birthday messages now that i'm out of
the code
now that i'm out of the coveted fog so
if you text that number
every morning um every morning or i mean
like yeah yeah yeah yeah if it's your
birthday you will get a message from me
follow us on instagram at good for you
podcast
i love doing this i read your comments
guys i'm working on the interrupting i'm
working on the
all the things so excuse me she's
working on turning her phone off during
recording
i have a call from beverly hills excuse
me
excuse me i gotta go take this someone
wants me to be in the pictures
i just walked in i i look like um uh
i look like the internet thinks i look
you look great thank you but thank you
so much i like it yes
thank you so much very antifa
uh tricks you've been telling you look
like you're about to storm the capital i
know
so i do need a little bit of lip gloss
uh
same chris de stefano yeah such a fan
i'm are you what are you kidding me i'm
a fan i agree
i love it does everyone mispronounce
your name yeah so annoying it's whatever
though do you just have to make that
your name now
um yeah well it's like kind of whatever
people say i just go with
whatever pronunciation they want it's
interesting because it's kind of
the one word you can pronounce no one
else can pronounce
right exactly it is a little bit ironic
even in my own family like my father
says d stefano
and his sister says destefanel some
people smell spell it with a capital s
i spell it with a small s because i'm
just like emotionally out of issues but
i'm just not confident yeah but yeah i
don't know i mean whatever you want to
call me i don't care are we friends
a thousand percent we are absolutely new
friends new friends
new friends new friends i don't want you
look like you're convincing yourself
right now
i'm legit friends with you we are i
swear to god i'm friends with you and
i'm the type of person i'll be friends
with you no matter what you do to me
i could just get over it like very
quickly i don't hold on to anything
really
yeah dude i'm just not that person um
okay
walk me through that what like i just
don't i just don't get bent out of shape
around for anybody like whatever people
want to do i'm just cool
my whole goal in life is just to be like
happy every day yeah and just like push
my kid in a swing
so we're new friends new friends but i
feel very close to you
i feel very close to you too i feel very
close to benton because benton
has been dming me for how long benton
for ever since lucy told me to say a
year shout out lucy from nashville
from zany we love lucy that's how benton
i met that's where we met
yeah and if benton i said before if
benton ever wants to you know come at me
in two years i have all the
the messages he sent me screenshotted
and in my lawyer's office
[Laughter]
you have a lawyer yeah
why did you stop history hyenas no well
be just because
just because we wanted to do like other
things like we
i was like you know like we just we're
talking about history like uh there's a
lot of times where like
you know giannis shout out iana's poppas
wanted to do other things and i want to
talk about other things and we're like
oh like we did this podcast it was so
fun
for three years let's just go support
each other and do the other way so
that's what that's the only reason why
we like how do you know you're done like
how do you like we we like
i think like i think like we just kind
of got to because we're friends first
that's the thing we were friends first
we were like yo like sometimes like
you know we're only been like meeting
once a week just do the podcast we don't
talk anymore like
dude like you know it's just a podcast
like money is like what whatever dude
like well
let's be friends failing that's what
you're saying yeah no
actually it was doing pretty good i did
great i was supposed to be on it and
then
i know we were about to be on i was
about to do it the day the pandemic hit
in new york
when that pandy hit it yeah it did you
did not and you flaked
i didn't fucking flake no you pussy
because i was like new yorkers
i'm like an la snowflake idiot i'm in
new york i'm like fucking i'll go do the
podcast right now everyone's like get
out of new york i'm like i said yes to
this podcast no
it wasn't me our producer the producer
was being
they were scared of coving yeah yeah
everybody who was scared of covert in my
life they all got it
but the ones who just came out were like
listen i'm going raw dog it's like i
kind of feel like covert showed up to my
body when like there's too many viruses
here
we've already attacked this body enough
this is too crowded this is too crowded
but but it was a good you know it was a
great show and like you know like yeah
dude
it's uh it's interesting to know when to
call something i'm fascinated by that
i usually get cancelled before i it's my
idea to do something yeah but it's uh
that's an interesting very mature adult
thing to go you know like we had a good
run
yeah and like people you know and that's
the thing like another lesson i learned
like with the internet like people will
create all their own narratives and it's
just like it's been like a good lesson
for me to just like let it go in like
one ear and out the other because peop
the things some people are saying about
why we ended i'm like dude that is so
not true but i just
whatever i kind of feel like i mean i
don't owe anybody we
jonas and i both don't owe anybody an
explanation of why it ended we know why
it ended and we were just happy that the
fans began happy people liked it i'm
kind of obsessed with that you used to
be a physical therapist
i did i was i technically well i
actually still am now i wasn't and now
my license got reinstated during the
pandemic governor cuomo from new york
uh reinstated everybody but cuomo he
never really got
people hated him they've hated him
forever they've hated him they got it so
why did they vote for him because nobody
votes in new york we didn't know and
that now people would know but like i
don't know fucking i never voted for the
governor or the
i mean mayor de blasio in new york
people hate him even
chris doesn't vote i don't vote and but
i legally can i'm not a felon as some of
you idiots may think
i'm not just not interested that's my
father my father legally can't vote he's
a felon for what
he when i was a kid he um he served
prison time
uh before i was a kid when i was a kid
for like you know loan sharking
racketeering all like that he was never
in the mafia i wanted to state my father
was never in the mafia
never was cool enough yes never was cool
his nickname is tony balls
but he never was in the mafia but he
played like he was with those guys
how do you avoid being in it and right
don't you kind of if you know stuff
you're
in yeah well he that's the thing like my
father my
the reason why i knew my dad because at
first my dad was like you know chris
when i was a kid like we'd go have to go
visit him in prison he would always tell
me he'd be like you know they got the
wrong guy like i'm innocent and i kind
of was like no you're not
like you know like your nickname is tony
balls like i know your friends like
aren't my uncles are all like goomba
idiots but when um there was a humongous
prison sting that happened in like 2007
2008 the fbi came and raided
and like kind of put the final nail in
like the new york italian mafia
coffin and it was a big thing in the new
york post front page of the paper 107 or
fb uh uh gangsters rounded up um
and there was all their pictures and i
remember looking at that photo on the
front page of the new york post i was
actually in graduate school at the time
and i was like
wow like 10 of those guys were at my
father's barbecue
three weeks ago like he is he does know
them
he was lying to me he's not interested
in cooking human hands yeah
you know what i gotta say though when
the mafia was there
i know when i was a kid we used to go to
like uh the festival in like howard
beach and like john gotti when we know
how to put on a park
john gotti would always give the kids
cotton candy if anybody i remember one
time this guy was like
like um was like hitting his girlfriend
or his wife these guys beat the shit out
of him like
the neighborhood was safe when the crime
was there yes i know that they do bad
things and
i know the cotton candy was laced with
pcp no but like i'm telling you that
whenever
new york was so much safer when the
mafia was there
i almost think like if you weren't a
store owner or uh
listen yeah listen you got to pay for
protection but you're protected here's
the thing it's like what do you what do
you want do you want to be protected or
do you want to get brickstone
and let me ask you a question the mafia
because i just did that
podcast for wondering that was about
sylvia berlusconi and
in italy and there's an amazing book
called gamora it's a
an investigative book by this guy and
published in 2006 which documents his
infiltration and investigation of
various areas of business and daily life
in italy in the italian mafia okay and
he got he got he got
no news outlets would let him promote it
like italy just shut down and would not
let the book get sold he couldn't get an
apartment all of a sudden it's like a
crazy story of this guy
right how does the mafia like was it
initially conceived as
what from what i understand to fill in
the gaps that the government to provide
the things the government wasn't
providing that was the initial it was
kind of like
some robin hood stuff initially in
sicily and then like anything else like
like even the things that are happening
in our country now there's always an
over correction
that's just as human beings we will
always over correct we'll always go too
far
good or bad always go too far so yeah so
the mafia then they started to
you know go too far like they got when
really when the maf
the only issue ever is when the mafia
started to get into drugs
that's like the old school thing like
that was one you shouldn't have done
that's why john gotti when he came in
and started allowing drug stuff
that's when peop that's when a lot of
problems start to happen it feels like
unlike history hyenas like it feels like
there's no good way for the mafia to be
like should we just call it no
it feels like once you're the mafia
can't just stop
here's the thing though here's i gotta
be honest for as much as the mafia i
mean listen you know they do dirtbags do
they on the internet like
are they texting like how has the mafia
not gone down in the day of the
interview
i'm telling you this mark my words
because nobody knows who really created
it
the mafia created bitcoin clip love it
clip that that i'm telling you crypto
the mafia created big pirate roberts is
an italian from queens
that's who it is that's who it is i'm
telling you what pilot roberto
and i'll be honest with you if with all
the stuff like going on if the mafia was
still around we would all be vaccinated
what
you know 100 you would we would all be
vaccinated for 200 cash yeah you get
modernise or whatever you want babe
that's what they say they'd open it up
you want johnson and johnson
that's 250. i
do have you seen this um uh show uh
uh your honor no no you gotta watch it
great is that that's without what's his
face brian cranston right yeah
and there's the there's i know emily
it's emily's christmas we were sobbing
watching it but there's this i don't and
then whitey bulger i'm obsessed with and
i do think
and rogan talks about this a lot him and
i were talking about it and i don't know
who's talking about on his podcast the
other day
i am so attracted to dangerous men sure
there's also it's very tricky because
um the mafia just i mean i i i'm
i'm in love with men it's so hard to not
love men that's why i'm here my mother
graduated from columbia university she's
an ivy league graduate person and my
father's nickname is tony ball
i mean why are you thinking why do you
think it's because my mother wanted a
fling with a bad
boy and then she fucked up and now i'm
here i remember being 17 years old and
kind of questioning my mom like why did
you do this right right like how did you
pass every test to get into colombia and
then you failed the tony balls one like
my dad could have been elon musk or some
shit no
i want the guy that's killed someone i
remember when i was watching that scene
in black mass i don't like to admit this
at all yeah and when he was choking juno
temple i was like yeah that's my god
about this and
you know you know what i learned so much
respect from my father especially like
you know in certain situations in my
life i'm like oh wow because my dad
always had like the right intention but
the wrong moves
because his whole thing was always like
hey like you need to protect women
always that's what it is i got an
engagement ring for my like seventh
birthday that i just wore as a ring
like i didn't know where it came from
you know no my dad is all
that's what the mafia is about respect
and i remember like going into when i
initially got into like my co-parenting
situation i remember
that my father you know and my mother
divorced when i was one but my father
always respected my mom like
and always when i was a little kid he
was like you always will respect your
mom you're the man of the house i'm like
i'm legit five but he was like you're
the man of the house
and so so i remember one time my mother
started dating this guy
who was actually one of my friend's
fathers but anyway he dumped my mom
and started dating a woman who lived
directly across the street like my mom's
boyfriend and my mother was heartbroken
and my father used to come pick me up
for like baseball practice or basketball
practice whatever on saturday mornings
and one time my mom he comes upstairs
and my mom is like sitting
looking out the window across the street
to
seeing if like her ex-boyfriend is going
into this woman's house who lives across
street and she was like crying
and i was playing video games in my room
because i was just like a snotty
teenager
and my father comes into my room he goes
what's up what's why is your mother
crying and i'm like
well that guy that she was dating he she
you know he dumped her and now he's
dating the woman across the street and
he was like you're gonna do something
about that
i was like i'm 14. like what what do you
want me to do about it like i have
psoriasis
i have i've proactive my wild acne you
want me to pop a pimple on his lip i
can't do anything dad i'm a child
and so my dad goes i swear to god he
goes don't leave the room i'm gonna go
get and he said like this he went
executive goes i'm gonna go get
bagels i was like okay you just did that
telling me not to leave now i'm 100
gonna leave so i start to creep down the
stairs
like two minutes later i swear to god
because my mother's looking out the
window
she starts screaming out the window
she's like tony tony stop you're gonna
kill him
my dad i swear to god was beating the
shit out of this guy
okay his name was brian across the
street beating him
i swear he comes walking back it kind of
felt like in goodfellas like when
yeah that like when ray leona comes back
he's like hide the gun karen i felt like
karen i was like what do i do
you know and he's coming back crosstalk
i swear to god he's got like blood on
his chin and blood on top of his shirt
and he goes that was your job that was
your job and i'm like again dad
i have psoriasis and now it's flaring up
because you've just tipped my emotions
so now i have an itchy spell my mother's
crying my dad and then
you had all the tools you need to rip
off your head gear and just fucking
start starting
a motherfucker yeah but my dad and then
i remember we were you know we're
leaving we went to staten island
and then it wasn't until like two hours
later we're sitting in traffic on the
verrazano bridge which takes you from
from brooklyn to staten island and he's
like you know i shouldn't have done what
i did back there right
and i'm like yeah you know i know mom
knows the police now we all know that
that was a bad move
he goes well i'm just saying next time
you have to protect your mother don't
just be playing video games you're
playing fucking sonic the hedgehog
while your mother's crying he goes never
let another man have to step in and do
that you protect your women and i'm like
okay
and then and then i kind of felt that
when i then i got because i got into a
situation then
where like you know my mother my it's
crazy how like the apple never falls far
from the tree either because oh god i
hope it does
no i'm fucked if it doesn't well because
my mom you know my whole life was
her being like you know she's this ivy
graduate my father's a criminal she
would always be like honey like
pronounce your r's you're not going to
sound like your father you're not going
to make that mistake i did you never
succeeded
[Laughter]
like i just said she's like you sound
like an idiot but anyway and she was
like you know like she
had this fling and she was like but you
will not make that mistake you will get
married you will do this you will do
that and i
and i went to school i listened to my
mom i never gotten any trouble you know
real truth
name lynn love never gone into any
trouble you know went through graduate
school and everything and like just
checking whatever you go to graduate
school for
i have a doctor in physical therapy wow
that's right okay so that's okay
so i literally i thought physical
therapist could just kind of
show up and dude no i thought so too
like you own him in a nice bath
it was such a confusing thing to like
because i would never call myself doctor
but like my
my kids who i graduated with like we're
gonna announce ourselves as doctor i'm
like that's the stupidest thing ever
like we can massage people's elbows like
don't
wait dude i i broke my shoulder right i
fractured my shoulder this direction and
tore my rotator cuff
i went to physical therapy i literally
every physical therapist so much i was
like you're this isn't real this isn't a
real thing
when i you i broke my shoulder i
literally had to take a thing and just
do this
yes for like 45 minutes for six months
because all because the main thing when
you hurt your shoulder like that is you
don't want to get frozen shoulder that's
was always trying to adhesive caps of
light
dude and then i had that that's fucking
impressive and then i had to do this i
don't know if you can see it
i had to just put my arm on something
yeah and just
gravity baby the swings but i wasn't
allowed to use my
it was so annoying and so hard and i'm
still not sure if my therapist was
accredited no i'm sometimes it looks
like bullshit physical therapy and
sometimes it probably is but i was a
pediatric physical therapist so i worked
with like
mentally and physically uh handicapped
kids so i felt like the impact there but
when i was doing orthopedics yeah i
first came out of school and i was like
this lady's bitching to me about like a
pulled muscle and a fucking pinky like
we take a break in this um uh
emotional rollercoaster of two people
that simply can't get enough attention
and cannot say enough quickly enough
uh to talk to you about my mustache
so i've been informed by my lover
uh who is just fearless he's a fearless
man he points out hair is coming out of
my moles he points
yeah i apparently have a bunch of moles
under my chin that have hairs coming out
like
like coarse
lost pubes that have migrated north
and he's recently pointed out to me that
i have a straight up mustache
i don't see it because i just shaved it
with my billy razor
amazing i i literally was like okay i'm
because he was trying to pluck it with a
tweezer and i was like we're not
tweezing it just it makes me cry
when i and i do that enough as it is i
don't need
help crying during the day and so i was
like i know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna get my billy razor and i'm
gonna shave my mustache
and i did it in the car not more not one
nick
that's amazing and if that doesn't make
you want a billy raiser i don't know
what will
i've never had a positive experience
shaving then i started using billion i
don't have that problem anymore
but razors i am like you guys know that
when you buy something that's a product
for a woman it's the same exact product
for a man except it's like pink
they charge you like seven dollars more
the pink tax men's razors are like a
dollar
for like 57 of them and then three
women's ones
is like 20. keep them in the locked
cases you have to ask
someone yeah to unlock the case so that
you can shave your taint it's
embarrassing
okay billy thank you for making shaving
our hairy bodies a pleasant experience i
don't have a hairy body
you can go to mybilly.com to get their
starter kit for just nine dollars
it's so affordable it includes their
award-winning razor two refill blades
and cult
favorite magnetic holder go to
mybilly.com
to meet the razor that everyone's
talking about i also did my unibrow
and it was the perfect it was perfectly
like i did i just
like what's good is that people are
getting less sexually attracted to you
they're an allure best of beauty winner
and nylon's beauty hit list for a reason
and to express a little love for our
show go to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us while getting the best razor you will
ever own
it's just nine dollars to get your
starter kit plus free shipping always go
to mybilly.com whitney
spelled my b i l l i e dot com slash
which name and we'll give a 30 minute
zoom call to the first person to shave
their entire head with a billy
goodbye if someone does that i'll fully
i will fully go through with that next
one not going to be worth it
i am getting to the point to where
i use doordash so much i don't even know
how to order in person anymore
this morning i have doordashed thrice
and it's 10 15. i forgot to get coffee
this morning and i thought well i'm just
gonna have a morning without coffee
and then i remembered doordash but no
not only
did i get a bunch of breakfasts that i
would never
like if i went to uh like starbucks or
something in person i just like all the
coffee and
like i just i don't think to or but when
i'm looking at the door dash i'm like
i'll have a pastry i'll have the first
i'll have a
crayon crayon apple scone yeah it looks
so much better on my screen
right if a handsome man's going to bring
it to me
i will nibble on a scone i'll nibble on
a skull but if it's just me in the
in line i'm like that's those aren't for
me they connect you with restaurants
that you love
right now when you give them the wrong
address
by accident right which i do most every
time
right they will call you and be like hey
am i going to the right place and you're
like no
right i had a good four-minute chat yeah
with a very charming man
great customer service it was he was
lovely and i get to start my day off
making a new friend yeah and not only
that you can get grocery essentials you
need with doordash get drinks snacks
and household items delivered in under
an hour
wow see it's feminism to order and not
cook
let's be honest let's be honest a true
equality is
thank you doordash they have over 300
for getting women out of the kitchen
they have over 300 000 partners in the
u.s puerto rico canada and australia
mate you can support your neighborhood
go to
choose from emily needs one
actively looking for one there should be
a dating app called australian
or choose from your favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
cheesecake factory
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code whitney2021
that's 25 off up to 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash
app in the app store enter code whitney
don't forget that's whitney code 2021
for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject
change emily gets a b
subject to change change oh my god i did
it again
should change terms don't forget that's
whitney 2021 i thought you were so smart
just because you can read
it creeps up on you
it'll get ya it gotcha it's a little
early for a bean yeah
just fyi this whole thing where we're
trying to actually read ads uh properly
so that we have sponsors and can
continue with our show
uh for you for you um uh we were doing
the bamboozled jelly bellies and if you
misread it you had to eat a jelly belly
we both got the stink bug one and we
currently
are both having um a mental wiring issue
where everything now tastes like stink
bug and we're just puking it's called
i'm gonna talk about it on another
podcast but it's called dis on another
podcast
podcast i'm gonna go talk about i'm
rogan you guys wouldn't get it
let's wrap up this ad where do you live
and are you moving to texas what's
happening
i'll never move to texas and and i love
california but i'll probably never move
here i mean i got to stay in brooklyn
babe i got to stay in bay ridge i can't
be too far from my mother
bay ridge it's just like it's a place in
brooklyn that like i love like i hope to
one day like be able to like write a
movie
about this and maybe i should start
trying now and stop waiting for somebody
else to do it i want to do this
but the the that neighborhood is so
insane first of all
i remember when i took my daughter
trick-or-treating in 2019
they they were going to dress up as she
she dressed up as um as a boss baby
she's just oh she's six right she's five
five have you ever had an
argument over the halloween costume um
have we ever
no the only arguments i've ever had has
just been with her mom like you know
if her mom if her whatever her mom wants
to do whatever her mom wants to do it's
like we got to do it but me and by the
way me and her mom
are uh are back together now me yes come
on here's what happened i got a while
listen shout out
she we got back together during
quarantine she got a lobotomy yeah she
got a lobotomy she forgot
her memory she forgot about all the bad
stuff that went on the mafia i had the
mafia go talk to her you ready for this
i had i had i had jimmy balls go talk to
him yeah and now we have a second child
on the way it's due july 4th
i swear to god chrissy the patriot i'm
naming it
thank donald a guy yeah look i mean yeah
what do you know if it's a boy or girl
wait july fourth john wouldn't know yet
we don't know if it's a
no we do know she doesn't want to know
because it's her third child so she
doesn't want to know
so but we uh i'm excited about it
hold on how long were you broken up two
years so so what happens with like
dating in between do you tell each other
i'm fascinated by this
me and my dude broke up for like four
months and i just found out
that he hooked up with someone and i
only went on two dates with someone and
i'm
listening here's the thing is is she
you know she when when we got back
together
i kind of we both kind of said because
when we first met
because what i was saying before is how
my mom got pregnant right away and was
like you can never don't ever do that
when i met my girlfriend you know six
years ago she got we got pregnant right
away she had a baby on like
the second date and then we went is that
true i swear to god and now and it's the
best thing ever happened to me because
you know i love
my daughter and she changed my whole
world at the time 30. it's almost like
you
having the kid and ra and and having her
for five years
turned you into the man that she could
yes could be with her but but then when
we break up and we're looking back and
we're like oh you know like whatever we
were great co-parents or whatever and
then we had said
you know when we were like oh if we ever
had a chance to like do it over again
like we would just date and do things
you never then we go then quarantine how
about this then quarantine happens
we kind of you know we didn't hook up or
anything but i was just like you know
coming around coming around and then
uh we i i leave and then i come back
again in
in we have like a monster now you're
also someone she can actually
justify dating but then i come back i
come back at the end of august
and we hadn't had sex in two years first
night we have sex
six weeks later she's like i'm fucking
pregnant again so we did the exact thing
that we did for my first child for my
second child just
it just doesn't stop with getting her we
just have kids
you're it's yeah this is um the universe
wants you to breathe i have children
yeah but did you attempt to not get her
pregnant were there any precautions in
place we're always attempting we to pull
and pray hello
but jesus isn't listening and and
and so and but listen we don't regret
anything we're both like look we love
being parents we love our child but my
stepson
you know who's 10 like he was confused
he was like whose kid is this
he's like well you're back and i'm like
he's like okay
he's like yeah is that whose kid is that
is that my dad's kid he's like i want my
family back i have this fucking idiot
in here it keeps coming back and forth
that is so what a
bummer man me and my stepson's father by
the way are like this so my girlfriend
hates it we fucking
love each other we like we love we love
being friends we love our families and
he's just like dude yeah
and she's like why don't you guys like
each other like he's the fucking man why
don't you ever break up with this guy
he's got so much inside info on bitcoin
it's unbelievable i'm obsessed with this
uh
my ex-boyfriend i sort of cheated on him
with one of his like heroes
it happens and he and then uh
uh and then when uh he was like all
upset we were living together i cheat
with one of his heroes i
kind of leave him for one of his heroes
i'm with one of his heroes and he calls
me like six months later and he's like
do you guys want to hang out
like he was like i'm over it like just
i'm just curious if you guys want to
maybe get dinner
like i'm cool but see like but i get
that because again if that happened to
me if if
my girlfriend left me for one of my
heroes i'd be like you know
whatever give me a couple weeks to work
through it and then we can just jump
back in let me ask you what is something
that and your next kid
you want to do differently than the
first kid like all right i figured that
i'm not gonna do that again not gonna do
that again yeah or like
i got it now i know to i think i think
the one thing that i you know so far
like with
with my daughter i think that you know
because i tried
the first one's practice yeah yeah let's
be honest this is a guinea pig yeah
there's a couple of things that i'm like
yeah that well that's going to be a
lifelong issue that i just created but i
didn't mean to but it's just something
she'll be a very successful comedian
yeah yeah it's what it is i think um
i think with you know a lot of times
with me
and and and my girlfriend we kind of
just would like
not talk to the kids about like the
problems we were having we would just
like
walk out and then come back and i didn't
realize like
even though my daughter was only one or
two when we first broke up i was like
her brain like she felt energy so
so i i'm very hell-bent on like working
it out
with her and like being honest and up
front with my kids about like everything
because kids know and when you and when
you um don't tell kids the truth if
you're fighting with your person and
you're like oh we were just doing an
acting exercise basically we were just
play acting
they started to doubt their reality no i
would i that's exactly what i would do
there was a couple of times
dad you're a bad actor yeah yeah there's
a couple of first words i know there's a
couple of times where i was like where i
was like you know
like you were arguing whatever and i i
actually said that i'm she was like why
are you yelling and cursing i'm like oh
i was going over my line she's like i
thought you got fired from beastmaster
um i'm like i did that's why we live in
this two-bedroom walk-up
that's why i'm doing pre-reads for ciso
yeah shout out
yeah but no but me and her me and my
girlfriend we're good now and we're and
everything's good and we're working
and we're trying to because we never
really had a chance
as a couple to every red flag that went
up for me or for her we just had to like
find a way to get around this because
you know we have a child coming on the
way and it was our first time we didn't
we barely knew each other we're trying
to figure this all out but now we know
each other now we're like
now we know like what pisses each other
off so you know
it's kind of like we don't do it unless
we just want to start a fight then one
of us will push that button
and we get you know and one of us throws
each other out every star fights
we get jokes oh yeah i do it all the
time it's so bad
yeah it's so bad now here's the thing
with my girl is you know there's
i've learned if she wants to see your
phone you give her your fucking phone
because because give her the phone yeah
it's not worth it we used to live in
this apartment let me just real quick
if you just give it to us yeah chances
are we'll go okay yeah
well chances are i won't look through it
if you just give it to me
if you say if you stutter or you flip it
over why do you need my phone you don't
trust me now i need to go through it now
i need to go through it yeah
yeah because let's go yeah sure yeah and
then she'll go oh oh yeah that was easy
yeah because i know i learned that and i
also were living in this apartment
building on the 12th floor and she was
like let me see your phone
because she's like real dear puerto
rican from brooklyn from sunset park
she's like let me get a tattoo on her
tit she's like let me see your fucking
phone and i was like
i was like no i don't want to show you
my phone she's like let me see your
phone and i was like no i don't want to
give you my phone she's like let me see
your fucking
phone when this is there's no way out of
that you're you're making it worse and
worse and worse
and i said what am i going to do what am
i going to do what was your concern what
was
why did she do you honestly want to know
what my genuine concern was but let me
tell you something or what
her concern so if you're if you show up
to dinner and this is your phone
and you flip it over i'm like yeah what
are you doing just flip it just open oh
just keep it up the concern i had is is
there was like
uh i had posted something and then an
instagram like model had reposted it in
her story and i had hearted
her repost and i'm like oh that's
business that's business
but then also but then the other part
was the other part was then there was
like you know porn stars we were sending
back and forth in the group chat it's
always the guy's group chat that i'm
like
oh you can't do that and i just was like
you gotta name the group chat
mom and dad but she knows that she knows
when i rename it she doesn't believe
anything okay that's fair because i used
to
cheat on guys and name them yeah cheat
with yeah wait on them yeah and name
them like bank of america
i know i should i got to think but but
we were on this plate and i wouldn't
give her my phone and like i said we
live in the 12th floor so guys
but let me slow down guys group chats
yeah that's not cheating though
no it's annoying as it is it's it's not
cheating i don't
love it right but there's a point in
your life where you got to go guys send
photos of girls to each other you're not
allowed to send naked photos of your
girls or girl
yeah sending porn star photos back and
forth like i don't love it it's not
ideal
but here's the thing though like if you
go to france it's like there's no
fucking rules there it's like you can
as long as you don't fall in love with
somebody else it's not cheating like you
could go have sex with somebody because
they're like yeah you're a human being
none of this is true i'm so sorry that
chris is lying to all of you france is
not like that at all guys
um i watch the pink panther and i'm
telling you it's true
none of this is true he saw one nude
beach assume they were all just fucking
violent i thought
i thought in france the rule was just
you can't fall in love with somebody
not true i dated a french guy uh when i
was 19
and another guy talked to me and he
threatened to commit suicide that's my
first thing in
time in paris i felt beautiful i've
never felt more loved in my whole life
really oh wow it was really it was the
most romantic thing that's ever happened
to me
he he threatened to commit suicide while
i was eating a meringue
in his uh parents apartment he and then
his parents came home and i died in the
closet for like seven hours
with the meringue uh uh and wondering if
he was commit suicide
i used to have fun that was that's
that's so funny listen i used to be a
fun person that does sound like a lot of
people so much anymore yeah
i actually i actually looked him up on
facebook recently and he has a bunch of
kids and a wife and i was like
i just uh oh emily's got the gun okay
emily's got the gun
what does that mean when i interrupt i
get shot with a nerf gun oh why
because i interrupt too much it's almost
impossible to interrupt you
but you've been you've managed what did
what what was she even interrupting
i didn't hear the rest of the story
about your girlfriend going through your
phone
don't go to my phone is upside down oh
yeah yeah oh that that yeah
so i gave her the phone because we were
living we were living on the 12th floor
and she was getting madder and mad and
married and then she kicked our air
conditioner out the window
so see it's good thing we came back to
that yeah that's incredible she kicked
her eggs she kicked director out the
window and then i gave her my phone
because i was like yeah hikes i'm
obsessed with her but she's great yeah
what happened
um no and then and then what what
happened is what always happens and then
if 10 minutes later she's just not mad
anymore she makes a sandwich and then
she's like
you know the kids are taking naps she
goes come in the bathroom and lock the
door and we have sex that's just what
always happens
is i almost think she starts fights with
me because she's horny and then it's
like
so you want to scare me and kick the
actors out the window and tell me you're
gonna fucking she told me she was gonna
like disney world on fire because she
thought i was going to disney
with my daughter and another woman but i
want my daughter and my mom but she was
like i swear to fucking god i will like
disney world i'm fucking fired
i love her yeah yeah yeah it was crazy i
was like i'm going with my mom
i'm with my mom and our daughter she was
like right let me find out you would
another bitch
i will fucking like goofy's ass on fire
i am obsessed with him she's the best
okay she's totally my hero but let me
but now that you're in a a you
monogamous relationship but this is yes
what proactive
things can guys do to avoid this because
guys will be like oh no i'm just
following a porn star when you
reengage in a committed relationship
with a woman
do yourself a favor invest in your
future self in serenity and standing
unfold just unfold the porn stars if you
need to go if you want to go to the
pornstar site on your own time
why do you just do a instagram
hygiene phone cleanse that's what i do i
just i don't follow anybody like that
and now i always post
i post my content that i that i need to
post and then i get off i don't check
the comments i don't check the dms
i stay out i'll stay off this i'm pretty
much off social media
get ahead of it i'm ahead i don't want i
don't want to you know what i mean
because it's like
listen dude like i'm just like it's all
trouble there you gotta clean up
your shit when you get in your yeah i'm
saying you gotta tie up the loose ends i
even when
when oh random randoms reach out to me
from a year and a half ago and they're
like what's good i'm like
just you know i'm like so that i've got
the text right there if they text again
i can say i drew a boundary
i'm not encouraging this i'm not you
know yeah yeah protect yourself
and i don't care i mean you know like
there's there's even sometimes like
there's uh there's been a couple of like
girls throughout the years like they'll
send like a picture and i'm like i'm not
responding to that and then they keep
going
like you're making me feel like a whore
you're making me feel bad i'm like what
i don't want to open your picture
because if i was
i wrote back to one girl i was like
listen it's not me you need to worry
about if my girl sees this shit you're
fucked
she's gonna follow you home she'll jump
out of your fucking bathroom and she'll
kill you with an empanada
so you better be careful i would just
tread lightly
every girl that's in the podcast just
tuned out yeah they were just like never
mind yeah yeah
no it ain't about me if if if she
catches you
so are you gonna get married um
i the thing is she's to love my life i'm
obsessed with her when you get married
a little suffocating we need to take it
slow we only have two kids
two children's together i'm obsessed
with her i don't know the marriage thing
feels like a big step
i don't know i mean maybe i mean we'll
let's just we'll have our second child
and then we'll see if you were going to
propose um
if i was going to propose how would i be
bobbing and waving mommy
yeah i'm sorry i know yeah
if i was going to propose you never
thought about this well here's the thing
i did actually propose to her when she
got pregnant
when we had our first child because i
was like yeah i was catholic and i was
just like you know
my mother was putting the pressure on my
mother was like you need to marry her
and i'm like you're right mom
and then i proposed to her 25. at that
point i was 30.
okay and and i was like emotionally 25.
i'm a dude
15. yeah and and um i proposed to her
and then uh i just i i had her
i did it outside of her apartment and i
had her mom and her whole family like
filming
it and like um so you did it for
tick-tock
well at that time it was vine sweetie um
so
no i i did that because i was like oh
like this will be like a fun video like
we can like look back at and like share
and then like
two months later she was like well you
know we're not getting married we're
just it's not gonna happen
and i was like okay and then and then um
and then i and then we
then we got re-engaged and then we kind
of just it kept just like not happening
but then we're like let's just be happy
being parents and
but now now we're i got to be honest
with you i think
we're very happy now being a couple and
parents like i feel like
we've grown so much as a couple going
through so many hard times like i'm kind
of like
happy that the things worked out the way
they worked out pose next time let's get
what are we doing i'm good um i'll
propose i'm obsessed with i
came up with the best idea for andrew
schultz's proposal he did not take
my advice yeah um uh i'm good at pro i
don't know i'm good at
thinking of proposal ideas i want i
suggested that he go into a uh
photo um what are those things called
photo booth photo booth and just bring
it right there
boom but then it's kind of a dumb
because it's it's four pictures gonna do
you could have a video of it you know
what i'm gonna do she's got a couple of
family members
um who are here uh illegally so i think
what i'll do is i'll make believe
i'll i'll have my friends dress up like
ice and they'll come in
and and they'll be like you know wear
ice and then one of them will come out
and be like but i got the real ice and
then they'll come out with a diamond
ring
and put it on but then also ask for
their passion so now you're legal and
we're not
can we marry you yeah i know i don't
know
yeah i'm gonna marry all of you oh
you're legal
yeah i know i just did an episode on my
podcast um chrissy chaos
with uh i saw that do with with j with
my girlfriend's
uncle uh transgender uncle tt jerry who
just got out of prison
he was in prison for 25 years and he got
married in jail
so she was like what the fuck like how
does tt jerry get married
and i still can't i've had a couple guys
come to me with proposal ideas where i'm
like
no brutal dude i had a one of my best
friends
uh her husband made her do like a
scavenger hunt
and like like earn the ring it was very
young i had to take her through like a
scavenger hunt and not tell her what's
going on like no i think that's power
stuff
because i think a lot of guys think like
this is the last thing i get to be in
charge of before the wedding what i'm
saying
right i no see that this thing the
relationship bombing is just is
very clear i have zero power and i am
not in charge
and that's just what it is i mean she
you know she has my credit card and the
money and that's about
it because but i like that i don't like
feeling the pressure they do in japan
right the man earns money gives it to
the woman and she's in charge of
everything it's just easier that way
because the scariest thing to me the
scariest thing on the planet and the uh
things is so gross is like an insecure
guy
uh every time i see an insecure guy i'm
like oh shut up
he's like oh my fucking girl's doing
this i'm like yeah dude you're a pussy
shut up dude just bow down that's what i
do i just bow down to women
true immediately bow down true power
is being able to relinquish power or at
least make other people think they have
the power
yeah yeah yeah i just no i'm i'm
genuinely terrified of herself
okay i'll tell you i also think
something amazing happens in your life
especially as comics because we i'll win
eventually
sure i'll i'll i'll hurt you yeah
i'll i'll i'll destroy the way you
perceive yourself
yeah i'll i'm trained to say the meanest
thing possible
100 i think about that all the time like
there was a big there was a debate
in my family what they were like oh
because my daughter's name is delilah
destefano and they're like oh
dee dee dee dee she's going to get made
fun of him like if anybody makes fun of
my kid i'm a professional comedian i'll
call fucking david l
and we'll write like legit roast level
like i'll have a six-year-old and fuck
i'll
their family will commit suicide dude
you don't get heavy hitters dude
comedians we don't if you hurt someone
we love we're just too
we are armed to ruin the way you see
yourself forever as comics it's like i'm
telling you dude try to make fun of my
daughter or my kid or my stepson
and see what happens just see what
happens to you with words
the words are going to hurt i don't need
to beat you up i will i'll ruin the
your brain yeah my daughter can read now
that's that's you can you can heal from
a bruise i'm going to hurt you in a way
you can never heal you can never you
know i'm going to take the thing that
bothers you the most about you and your
family and your body and i'm going to
fucking i'm going to give you an
insecurity for their i'm going to give
you an eating disorder 100
is what's going to happen dude you're
going to be so miserable you're going to
defect and join isis that's how much i'm
going to fucking ruin your life
but your kid needs some adversity yes
they do need adversity which is why you
being a parent is enough
that's probably all they need actually
you know i have a cousin who fucking
planned her pregnancy she's the worst
lady oh just like what do you mean
pregnancy is not a bad thing no i'm not
playing i didn't mean it like that she's
the worst problem that's what most
people do
no no but we had i see i disagree i want
to take the stand we did the unplanned
pregnancy yeah
and my kids are survivors okay we're not
promoting unplanned pregnancies on the
good for you podcast
uh we support planned parenthood
no i support planned parenthood do
whatever you want your your
your body your choice if you get raped
keep it that's what chris
is saying well i'm just saying i'm just
saying that
if uh my daughter was unplanned so the
things she survived in the embryo
yeah was insane but most of us weren't
plant i mean
certainly my generation if you're the
second third or fourth kid you probably
weren't playing yeah do you think like
the winners of world war ii their moms
were having planned pregnancies no way
dude they were shitting those kids out
and then they were putting them in
parachutes and going into nazis okay
they were no they were sending them to
work to work dude yeah but like my
cousin you know she lives in maine and
she's like plans everything and now her
son has a fucking peanut allergy i'm
like yeah that's your fault lady
my daughter the shit my daughter's mom
was doing cocaine when we were two
months pregnant because we didn't know
that there was a baby
nobody knew there was a baby happening
so my daughter survived it all and she's
great but you know my fucking
cousin's kid she's gonna be so cute
because she's gonna stay small forever
you know
you wanted something she's the best but
my cousin's kid i mean he has to blow
out his
candles on an ipad because he's allergic
to candle smoke it's like dude you're a
pussy
it's because your mother planned you
that's the issue does
uh delilah have any allergies delilah
has zero allergies
she's yeah no delilah friend of mine uh
was worried about her kid a peanut
allergy so she drove her to the
emergency room they sat in front of the
emergency room
gave her a peanut and just sat there for
an hour and drove off dude you know i
swear to god we were in the
pediatrician's office like
three months ago when my dad my dad
moved to tampa now but when he was there
we took her to her pediatrician
appointment
and he was with me and i swear the
doctor was a new pediatrician the doctor
said we don't have her most updated
chart he goes does she have any
allergies and my dad goes yeah
democrats and the pediatrician was just
like
uh limptard yeah i was like wow dad shut
up
that's cute that he comes to the
pediatrician my dad you have to
understand my dad like legit like may
have assisted in hiding and dismembering
dead bodies when i was younger or before
i was bored
that he loves my daughter on some level
do you think he's falling around to
protect her because he thinks
that maybe his mistakes in the past
could haunt
the family that and i think he knows
what a pussy i am so he's probably like
it might
my son's not going to do it this kid's
uh fucking he's got eggs
he couldn't beat up an adult he was 14.
beat up his mother's boyfriend
but no you know it's funny you know not
funny but like cute when they moved to
tampa my stepmom
told me she was like oh she's like we
were cleaning out the house moving she's
like and we found this little doll
that we had gotten when delilah was
first born and
it was like buried back and there was a
little baby diaper on it and i'm like
what do you mean and he was like she was
like your dad used to practice
diapers on your daughter's dolls and
like we forgot she was like he would
never tell you that she's like don't
tell anyone that i was like well i'm
telling everybody on whitney's podcast
i'd always do my you know change my
daughter's diapers even my girl gave me
credit she was like i gotta be honest
like you
change diapers like you really get in
there i'm like yeah absolutely like i
you know i've i've cleaned shit out of
you can't imagine where baby shit gets
into
my own mouth i mean her ears like i'm
like how do you how did you shit in your
ear
but you just got to clean it out and do
it i love it though and i love being
like a girl
dad so i'm this child if it's you know
people like don't you want to be a boy
i'm like not really because i just feel
like you know i mean whatever i wanted
to be healthy of course but i like just
having
a girl is there any like as like because
i think that i and then we're gonna i'm
gonna ask you one more question and then
we're gonna get to games we have some
games
bent are you good baby yeah i'm great
ben is about to come in and play games
with us oh fucking i love benton dude
great hair i think he's got great hair
he's an icon he is an icon he is that's
good he's iconic
yeah yeah you have the same hair as my
mom that's that is that hair
that's like my feelings my mom's trying
to be trendy and cool i'm like i got a
hook yard with benton
wait did she did she die yeah yeah she's
got the little guy
your mom also got a tick-tock she was
like great
she blows past us all on tick-tock last
question
which is i feel like i'm always have hot
takes with like
this is something kids should be
watching is this should little girls
play with this toy like i'm always just
in that area right and then i'm sure
people roll their eyes like oh whitney
no one was traumatized by wizard of oz
or whatever
is there any toy that your daughter has
gotten where you're like
don't love the message um i don't
love it uh i was lucky i got i didn't
get a lot of toys as a kid i got my
little ponies mostly
but my daughter has like 20 of them
those are my shit i was a horse kind of
girl yeah
are there ever like movies or anything
where you're like oh that's a weird
message for a five-year-old
yeah no man will save you white knight
wait for the man
like any of those where you're like
honey that's not real well it's one of
those things where like to be honest
with you i guess like being in
comedy and trying to be like aware of
like everything that's going on because
the thing is like
you know being in entertainment it's
like all these issues these hot button
issues like
they're in our world but like the
average person like just doesn't care
they're like oh i gotta figure out
your child average how to like make
money no i'm calling my
child's mother average um and yeah
yeah i'm kidding you know i know she
heard that no but she there's a lot of
times they're like
i'll be like we were watching pocahontas
the other day
and i was like i was like i said to jazz
and my girlfriend i was like i was like
isn't it
jasmine the name's jasmine my
girlfriend's name's jeff okay and
there's a disney movie called jasmine
yeah princess jasmine but but pocahontas
i was like isn't it like we can't
like it's like kind of bad like they're
saying like native american people are
savages and call them savages and like
john smith is like the white hero i'm
like
isn't that like no good for her to see
and jazz was like no she was like my
daughter she was like fuck this you know
she was like everybody wants to get all
up in arms about everything my daughter
can
tell the difference between fiction and
she yeah and she and my she said
straight up to me she was like i'm gonna
tell i'm gonna tell delilah as she grows
up she's like honey
when in doubt get yourself a white man
she was like look at me she was like i
got saved by two white guys and i'm like
wow she said that
to my face and i was like okay i have a
feeling that jasmine would have been
just fine without both of you
both i know i don't have a stinking
suspicion no you know what you're
sinking suspicion or stinking speaking
jasmine is the one see that's the thing
she's the one that told me she was like
i was like i was like oh like look we
got a nice like multi-racial baby now
half puerto rican half white she was
like absolutely
she was like and i'm gonna tell you i'm
going to college she said she was like i
told her she was like listen on college
applications we're going to be puerto
rican on job interviews we're going to
be white
she was like that's exactly what she
said she was like that's how we're going
to do this i was like yes
so yes yeah so my point is like a lot of
the stuff like i'll be the one who more
will be like hey i think we should do
this and this and jazz would be like yo
stop being
she'll always call me she's like you're
gonna stop being a bitch she was like
my daughter will be fine she's like
we'll be fine as women and i'm like okay
all right i'm just trying to fucking i
don't know what to do i'm trying to help
but a lot of times i just get it
with comedians we see everything we just
we everything we see is uh we're
professional complainers we're
professional critics
you know so it's like every movie you
see like honey don't look you know yeah
i i'm always trying to like be like
earmuffs or whatever but you know
listen my my family's like very like
kind of like old school
too like i have a cousin who's a
firefighter like she's like a
was the only one in her graduating fdny
class and like she's like one of like
the toughest people
men or women i know i know like i
remember somebody tried to break it to
her house when we were 19
and she threw the burglar out the window
i'm like so this girl
like she just doesn't like sometimes the
women in my family i have to be like hey
wait how old was this bird like what
dude i'm i'm coming back oh
so who says burglar i go old school
who says this scalawag thanks galloway
because rap scallion came right up to
the window
both our moms were at work my cousin
used to live we all grew up in the same
house
and my mom and her sister and her kid
that's my cousin and we and i was coming
home
from like the store both our moms are at
work and i see the police and fire
department on our block and i'm like oh
my god they're right at my house i
thought something horrible happened and
then i see
this guy in handcuffs and he was like my
arms are broken
and i'm like what the fuck happened i go
in and my cousins she's like yeah
somebody tried to break in and i'm like
what did you do she's like i threw them
out the window i was like oh okay
crazy um did you see that sebastian
maniscalco the
intruder in chicago no okay so i know
his bit when he said he would shoot his
intruder with a bow and arrow did he
yeah that's right
no he oh his cousin or something like
that killed somebody no
so um sebastian mascalco's cousin is
named sebastian mezcalco
yeah and he lives in chicago and i guess
someone thought they were robbing or
burgling as you
as sebastian and they fucked with the
wrong
maniscalco yeah not that sebastian
couldn't have handled a burglar he could
have
i just feel like he'd be like let me
take off my yeah my bedazzle jacket
first before we handle this
i gotta do my hair from it to just
handle this like a gentleman
and then uh yeah the guy uh he
he went in the cousin whose name is also
special metascalca was the victim of a
home invasion
two masked men came in wow cousin
maniscalco shot
and killed a 58-year-old man
larry in self-defense after bradley
finnen who cares about these
motherfuckers forced their way into the
home in arlington you're exactly right
they were planning to steal two hundred
thousand dollars they thought was inside
the home
well don't fuck around that's the thing
if you want to mess with like even
sometimes like older people you
everybody about that story is with
italians in general
italians are generally kind of a rule
i'm learning or also like older guys
there's a story i feel like it was in
colombia maybe somebody tried to
like a senior citizen like old you know
boss was going around like touring
colombia and these colombian guys got on
and tried to rob them and one of the
guys
had fought in world war ii and he broke
the
the robbers um clavicle and it stabbed
him in the heart and he killed him on
the bus
and like but then they like went on and
like just like went to like the early
bird special like he was like yeah i've
killed nazis you don't think i can kill
this
colombian idiot with a fucking handgun
it was a wild story i was like what
and like colombia was just like yeah
thank you i feel like once the
collarbone's out of your body like you
don't need to stab the person in the
heart
it feels like you know he stabbed him in
the heart with his collar bone he broke
his arm
and then his collarbone stabbed him in
the heart like in
inside his body and he killed steve
irwin
yeah it's just what happens but that's
that's why you don't mess with old
people
they know how to do stuff dude when i
see old people like
in public uh like they'll have a
band-aid on their face
for like three days but you know what
old people will cut themselves shaving
and they'll just have a piece of bloody
toilet paper like young
and they're saying i dude yeah i will
never fuck with you i never fuck with
you at all when i was
at one time i was a physical and on all
those the war veterans they all fight
with each other like they think like
it's like the things they were saying
i'm like what i used to be a physical
therapist
at um the va hospital the veterans
hospital in new york
and i remember one of the rounds i was
doing
was in the same at the same time there
was a world war ii vet a vietnam vet and
an iraq vet and they all had sex i would
listen to that podcast dude and they all
had suffered like war
injuries and stuff and like the world
war ii vet would call the vietnam vet
and the iraq vets pussies they'd be like
you
you didn't do this you didn't do that
what did your tanks have they know how
much napalm have you snorted
that's what one of the world war two
guys said the world war zoo was like he
was like fucking napalm he was like what
is that bullshit
he was like i killed nazis with my bare
heads
he's like okay you killed a couple of
vietnamese whoopty fucking dude
nazis were stronger to be fair they were
on methamphetamine they were on drugs
dude
yeah they were on drugs i know dude it's
i know fucking panzer chocolate the nazi
nazis that stuff i mean they would
literally be on methamphetamine oh they
were on
fully like they called it tank chocolate
they would just take a pit of tank
talking and go wild that's why you ever
see those old videos of hitler when his
arm
he was like legit there's a drug addict
that's what that is and that's how they
got so much done in such a short amount
of time
their nazis created crystal methods that
wasn't like given to them they made it
yeah it was wise and what was the thing
about you
because you know so much about history
rogan uh told me about this one tonight
how they would
scar their faces really yeah they would
scar nazis would scar their faces
at just to look scarier well you know
the whole like skull and bones like when
you look at skull and bones you're like
ooh poison or negative
that wasn't even a symbol before the
nazis the reason why we look at those
symbols skull and bones and think like
danger
is because that was on nazi tanks
dueling scars the badge of honor of many
nazis they were part of the original
fight club an underground fighting gang
and they would uh uh when you got a
certain rank they'd give you a giant
scar on your face just so you look like
a scary but you know what
history is interesting because i read
this i like to read books
how do we know any of it's true well
that's the thing i always like i i hear
i heard the american versions of history
all
going through high school and college
when i go back and i look back at my
my uh i was helping one of my nieces
with zoom school i was like
i didn't learn this is i learned that
columbus came over
and found in america it's totally
different textbook
i wrote this i read this book the nazi
symbiosis it was called it was about
like
symbiotes sorry you know what i mean hey
what's up i'm fucking chrissy stupid ass
um um i i uh i read this book
and and it was all about how the nazis
became the nazis like what
what was it before the internet before
the internet
and it was like all the ideas they got
in the in the holocaust for like
gene therapy and like all this like you
know stuff that they would like
you know take holocaust victims and like
do horrible things and try to like mix
their genes and their blood to do that
they
got that from the british and the
americans they were the ones doing it
first
and they were the ones like gregor
mendel like kind of like with the um you
know
trying to manipulate the p's uh appease
genes and do that
the nazis were like oh they're doing it
that's where they stole the science and
then allegedly according to this book
you know the west uh the allies knew
like churchill
and and fdr knew that what was going on
in the holocaust but they were yielding
results the nazis were yielding results
with like there's a lot of things that
happened with medicine like
out of the holocaust and they were like
oh let's not raid that
until you know because they're getting
these results we can make money and
doing this it wasn't until
they stopped getting results and hitler
kind of went off on you know and was
like oh i want to go attack russia and
kill everybody in russian
he was like just kill everyone in the
holocaust camps and they stopped doing
science
then they liberated the camp so
sometimes it gets murky with history i'm
like ah not everyone's all good or all
bad here
and also it's like i'm doing this thing
um this project uh
uh in harpers ferry everyone's heard
about it um
that i work with but in harpers ferry
west virginia where the john brown great
that's beautiful the john
the harpers ferry west virginia house so
it's one of the craziest thing i've ever
craziest sceneries i've ever seen in my
life so my dream is to renovate that
hotel my dad managed it when i was a kid
right there where the john brown raid
and growing up i would uh
my babysitter was the john brown waxman
robert e lee came in he was the one
leading the chart exactly right uh
george washington surveyed the property
when he was 17 years old
it's the most beautiful property i've
ever seen in the united states thomas
jefferson said it's the only view worth
the trip across the atlantic it's
just beautiful it looks like narnia it
looks like new zealand yeah my goal is
to have movies come shoot yeah to bring
money they have a candy store there
where they make candy
shops yeah that's right and so this is
the john brown museum we'll show some
images shout out john bleeding kansas
when i grew up
i would go to this john brown museum is
the most terrifying thing on the planet
do you think john brown's hot or no this
he's so hot i know a lot he was played
by a one ethan hawk in the uh
and looks kind of like yeah john brown's
a honey was a hottie and he
he was the first um you know
that was i mean maybe not the first and
it just wasn't documented like i
whenever you
read this history and i'm getting all
these documents that there's like
literally no history on like discovering
all these
like slaves that like no one's ever
written about sure
you know uh in these revolts that no one
ever documented their lives and finding
journal entries and stuff like there's
so much stuff that we just like do not
fucking know or we know through
a lot a lens that's just not true but i
would uh spend my childhood that's
probably why i'm such a twisted person
at this wax creepy ass john brown wax
museum
and uh it's my dream to rebuild you grew
up in harper's ferry
i spent my summers there that i that's
amazing i like la i wanna i wanna
i need to make sure my daughter sees
that place so look i will take you i'm
going on the 20th let's go
so look i've got i can't because of
covid oh this is like the deck
in west virginia uh
uh um they have the mobile vaccine
places in west virginia
like they'll pull up to your house and
give you a vax like subutex vans for
opioid over there's there's some vans
but they're not okay west virginia is
fascinating
there's flip sides they were on the
confederate and the union well
west virginia was the first one said
we're not doing slavery they broke
off to say we are not doing slavery no
for west virginia to now have this
reputation for being like backwards and
please watch the documentary hillbilly
by ashley york if you have not she's
actually directing this
yeah but you know why but that in my in
my opinion from the research that i've
done that's the confederate that's
confederate slander
it's from this day it's like because
they were pissed and when west virginia
flipped sides and
lincoln led virginia so now the
confederacy was like okay now we're
going to fuck west virginia and say that
they're hillbilly backwards people when
they never really were
time for a second break from christa
stefano he was
he was being too funny we need to slow
down yeah we need to get back
yeah we need to get back to us and
uh i think that if you've been listening
to this podcast you're probably going
whitney has a boyfriend
how is he possibly getting an erection
with that personality
and that mustache shaved it did you guys
see her earlier
i shaved the callback uh so look ed
is a big part of my life e d d
that's a big deal uh it's a big part of
my life as you may know because of the
um
uh uh my general vibe
you know i don't see that i'm a vibe
killer like as soon as as a guy wants to
get i'm like did you wash your hands
let's go like where did
you wash your yes i get ut eyes and i
have this
i have they're not supposed to do it
with their hands i know well no if
you're gonna put your hands all over my
body
and inside my body i'm like let me see
your nails i'm dating a rock climber his
nails are full of
rocks and like just who knows like
powders and
i don't know what they do but it seems
it's it doesn't seem sanitary he's in a
quarry most of the time
i just so i like kill a vibe
yeah i can kill a vibe fast i can see
that so his foreplay is washing his
hands yes but the rock climbers can't
get their hands wet because it fucks up
the skin calluses
so i'm like use a sanitizer it's gotta
burn a little
the whole thing's a nightmare but the
point is
roman comes in very handy uh to get
him back your man back up and running
when your personality has killed the
mood
with roman you can get a free online
evaluation on carrying ongoing care
shit for sorry the word care just might
have said right right right uh
for erectile dysfunction from all the
comfort and privacy of your own home you
have to be embarrassed
yeah not at all a licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate it ships to
you free free
two-day shipping so you can get that
boner back up and running
in time for bada-bing the new stormy
daniels joint here's the thing
a lot more guys are getting erectile
dysfunction these days i don't know i'm
not
saying every guy i've ever slept with
nope but uh
but with porn you guys are watching a
lot of porn the pandemic
right it's a guy you know a lot of stuff
is being done digital so by the time you
see a real woman these days you might
just panic
right right you're like what they have
pubes since wet
take care of your erectile dysfunction
without leaving your home
complete an online visit today to
connect with a healthcare professional
and take care of it
handle it go to getroman.com whitney now
you'll get 15
off your first month it's really time to
take care of your ed
and remember get started today and
you'll save 15 on your first order of ed
treatment my dad's name is ed so that
was like it's just weird to
read it
sorry daddy i love you you think you're
down listen to this
that's so true
honey okay and that's it
[Applause]
okay so ritual vitamins
play a very big role in my life and the
irony is that i've been using ritual
vitamins since before i started this
podcast
and i've been singing from the rooftops
how much i love ritual vitamins
getting my friends uh into virtual
vitamins but now that their sponsor
i cannot seem to talk about them without
saying the wrong thing or getting in
trouble oh the irony is i love this
product so much
but i i'm like it changed my life and my
hair's
like i believe it's done so much for me
but i think legally i'm not allowed to
say
most of the compliments i want to say
about it so i'm gonna let emily take it
i'm too enthusiastic too enthusiastic
you love it too much i love it too much
ritual is a multi-vitamin reimagined
look this is the
uh vitamin look how cool it is it's you
can see it and it's a minty smell
is it gonna smell like a chili no it's
not gonna oh that is refreshing
like you take it so that you don't have
like a nasty wharf burp
after it oh great this is me during the
virtual ad i have to i have to duct tape
my face
okay let's just we can make that a
regular thing
a multivitamin should contain key
nutrients and forms your body can
actually use to help fill gaps in the
diet no shady extras
ritual's delayed release capsule design
delivers high quality nutrients
including vitamin d3 in just two daily
pills rituals designed with your life
stage in mind
now available for women men and teens
ritual multivitamins are scientifically
developed to help support
different life stages get key nutrients
without the bs ritual is offering my
list
get key nutrients without the bs rituals
offering our listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com whitney to start your ritual
today
okay so now we're going to play some
ridiculous games benjen is going to
explain what's the first one
so we're going to start off with um
doing one where we're going to go
through all we're going to go back to
old tweets
shit and we're going to see if you guys
can guess the three of you can guess
which comic these tweets are now they're
all people that are like your friends so
they're nobody like randy
a year old or like they're old so you
don't need to know how i'll deal
okay um if they're mine can you not be
yeah please we're gonna start with this
one okay
how are all these women so pissed off
about wearing masks
um wait no who wrote this if it that
sounds like bobby lee if it's spelled
wrong
how are all these women so pissed off
about wearing masks but okay with
wearing underwire push-up bras and
thongs
whitney that's something that's me
that's a hundred percent whitney is that
me
i was gonna yeah i first i went that's a
good joke yeah
you said i like that it is wrote wrong
and you if it's right wrong it's bobby
lee
what idiot wrote that i know i was gonna
catch whitney or donald trump
that's right whitney or judy judy to
shout out judy teduna okay next one
imagine someone gifting you their dick
pic in one of those homemade macaroni
picture frames for valentine's day
that um imagine someone
[Music]
gifting you their dick pic in one of
those homemade macaroni
pizzas no
what did you used to be roommates with
andy last night didn't i make that up
yeah no no i was me andy letterman and
mike racine i don't know if you know you
never date i don't
annie and i never dated no it's so funny
and i never tried to date i never did
that any yeah yeah
yeah i never did it yeah dude who
doesn't fucking love danny best
the best i we started doing open mics
together the same time in new york city
i was so scared of her for so long and
i'm so bummed how many years we lost
together because she wore such big hoops
and
a belly show women that just wear cut
off belly shirts at night to do stand-up
i just was like dude
i'm i was just i love her she's so nice
dude and then before the pandemic we
just like we're like oh
no yeah we're obsessed with each other
but we were like like panthers at the
comedy store we kind of never
never talked you know and now yeah
i can't get out of my fucking house
fucking annie um okay next one oh we
don't know who that is macro dick
picking a macaroni
um dick picking america macaroni is it
um uh taylor tomlinson um
no no um give us a hint is it not a
woman
no it's a man aunt
that's just really trying to write jokes
these days yes follow him
i drink almond chocolate milk i'm gay
that's me that's me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's me
i drink almond chocolate milk i'm gay
yes and that wasn't me that was
that was my father actually i just was
paraphrasing all the responses back to
you
are they they're all were saying why did
you write this sentence backwards
i drink almond chocolate milk instead of
i drink chocolate almond milk
well because i'm christy dyslexia and i
i love that you didn't give a shit you
were just like no at the time i meant it
yeah no i don't care i'll just keep it
up i have a huge gay following shout out
and the biggest transgender fan base on
the east coast that's a fact last one
instead of saying i like garment
parmesan wings
you can just say legally i'm not allowed
to see my daughter
[Music]
it's a good tweet that's so funny that's
a funny tweet that's well written
who is that that's a greg geraldo i was
gonna say man that's is that something
oh that's a good compliment uh uh colin
quinn david tell david
it's gonna be a guess there's a tweet um
to clarify old tweet not an old person
it's an old tweet not an old person
is
when you say who it is all right who is
it tell me it's tim dylan tim dylan
timmy no that's a very old tweet because
he's not like trying to start some shit
yeah
january 25th 2001. oh really
he didn't tag airbnb i thought that how
could it be timmy
i don't recognize it without you tagging
rogan
wait that tweet is 19 year 20 years old
no what 20 21 is now
i know you said two you said 2001.
uh whatever i'm disliked it too there it
is now what are you gonna bully everyone
welcome to the squad yeah exactly
how do you know what it feels like we
have meetings
on thursdays and tuesdays nobody won
that who lost
everyone literally no one got one that's
the other game actually one because i
knew the whitney tweet i'm the only oh
yeah you're the only one to get a point
well i guess my own please
so you just have to eat a jelly i mean
what was the the consequence there was
no consequences
okay so what's the next one the next one
is comedians uh heads up
i know the next one is i thought is that
what you want to do yeah let's do it
okay so i'm gonna put a committee on my
forehead and you guys i have to guess
who it is based on you guys
either saying they're jokes you can't
say their name you can't say their
podcast you can't say a name of their
special you can't say
um anything that's going to give it away
immediately yes you have to each
it has to be something in their act or
an impression of them i think we'll all
guess whitney's and then when it's your
turn we'll get yours very scottish
very self-explanatory you have a but if
i hold this up
we need to get rid of the monitor
because i will see it so let's lose oh
yeah we'll all see
what i'm saying so do you guys do these
games every week or is it a new game no
just when we think a guess is going to
be boring
thank you well yeah i am putting on
emily while you're here
okay great i sue okay ready
i can't see it okay okay um
i love cars cars there it is so now it's
chris's turn
it's my turn got it pick one all right
so i pick one
okay and i just put on your forehead
okay hold on i know because i saw that
one so i wanted to
um um uh um
oh ucb um witch hands apples
um trolls goblins i mean can we say
broad city like
um
i got chipped um uh she just got married
her wife's really hot
[Applause]
it's so funny okay then emily okay
this hasn't we've been burning bridges
yet this is shocking quick
let's flip it over oh oh glasses
all the time yes
they're like not whitney cummings i was
like
what you're telling me
[Laughter]
i look like her now snl old school
no the the the most iconic female
comedian uh after may west and before
joan rivers philosophy yes there you go
she was an snl what's she not looking
for
loves whitney friends good friends with
danny letterman thank you
yeah do like he's so talented the one
communion you like
so talented his family they own like all
the same who they dated can they say who
they are
they will his family will press a button
and he will die
i don't think a lot of people know that
i'm sorry well there you go
wrong person who pisses off all right
here we go uh turn over oh
uh i don't know um oh um
it's a lot of this when they're on
yeah i'm visionary brilliant your hero
you're a hero
wow oh yes by the way everyone froze
when they came up and they're like
everybody was like she's a great staff
okay
turn it over um
thick boy cauliflower here
is it brendan yeah good job okay
turn it um tick tock big t
big all tick-tock top exploding
tick-tock
tick-tock quarantine yeah to quarantine
trump someone i tried there you go yes
yes yes yes yes
that could have gotten way meaner
she's a unicorn uh she ready she's ready
oh she's six nine
[Laughter]
uh kevin hart tiffany yeah
she's blaming other people i know you
know what okay
guys we're good at that i know this is
legit i mean i'm not but you guys i
haven't got one wrong yet
um
mine are very easy i know you're getting
really easy ones um i'm surprised we
haven't uh
hurt anyone's feelings yet let's heard
emily here we go
tom uh uh she has a great joke uh she's
uh um
um babies have skills of justice
skeleton gloves shoes
loves is like she's from the 20s
yes she's very tiny her husband is
definitely circumcised
her husband natasha
um of the queen the queen of the red
carpet
um yes
the babe the great my favorite
uh-oh um
yeah was that that was a catchphrase
that or like that was an asshole
that's not city
um okay let's do one more round okay
turn over um
turn around i mean it has billions of
john dollars he has everything except a
right arm
oh yeah he's a great basketball player
he loves fans amazing athletes
incredible basketball players
i don't understand that was the most
painful
looking break i've ever seen it was
crazy he has everything except the right
arm
it made no sense the way he felt
i'm sorry again i i know it's really
serious but i i really lose my shit when
people
fall and i just can't stop that one was
brutal though i was like oh my god
emily fell the other night at the i'm
sorry she fell at the improv
and she fell hard hard
i'm doing a show on friday night uh in
tomorrow night uh yeah come do it
uh there's there's a lot of cool like
outdoor shows popping up okay i'll text
you because i've been dying to get on
stage yeah inside's gonna be soon but
yeah it's uh these outdoor shows you're
on a stage it's like
50 150 people outside it's a blast do
you ever do the shows here anymore uh
where
and you didn't choose to do that i used
to do them outside here yeah i always do
i was doing that for a while and i'll go
back to doing it
um but it was like i was paying so much
money for testing you know what i mean
and then all right i'll find out what's
going on
the internet like you're spreading it oh
god get out of here
turn over um she
opens everything but this is the best
joker so many dead babies
babies anthony jones yes yeah
dead babies my teenage years uh turn it
over
um uh just pulled this show off of
netflix
he put he put that c symbol on the side
of a ventilator if you could
um he took his show off of netflix he
lives in ohio
yes okay last one turn it over we
already did it oh did it
did it
[Laughter]
christopher reeves that's great
that's literally christina's yeah tom
segura is the new superman that i need
to see that movie
and then are you on tour yes uh well uh
no right now
um because i'm doing the show hosting a
show for true tv called backyard bar
wars
can you try to wait uh find a way to not
make a racist joke
yeah on the show yeah you know yeah i
kind of
i kind of i told them as soon as they
hired me i was like you've listened to
my podcast right and they were like yeah
we wanted to be edgy i'm like okay they
always say you listen to the first 10
minutes
yeah and we're like this is fun yeah no
no no no no no
i went they asked me on the mask uh
dancer to be a judge
and i went out there brian austin green
was one of the judges who i fully
was in love with when i was a kid and i
went and paul abdul was there
and can ken dr ken and ashley tiso and i
just went out like
guns blazing i was like i'm only here to
fuck brian austin green that's what
i wouldn't love it they stopped down
yeah
all like five people came out with like
clipboards and they were like you we
need you to truly stop like it was like
because there were people in the
audience and it was being recorded and
they're like we need you to stop talking
but um but you know what though like
it's a kid's show but it's also a kid's
show
but that's why i love doing the podcast
that's why the podcasts are so beautiful
because like we don't have to be in that
box we could just be comedians and like
be the group of people that
say things you're not supposed to say to
like give relief to society and also we
this is you know that we like to go into
dangerous territories yeah even if we're
we uh uh say things we don't mean or we
just we have to be able to like have
these
uncomfortable conversations and be wrong
and we're idiots we're comedians like
why don't
why i don't understand why now there's
this thing where like comedians jokes
define who they are it's like they're
jokes it's like if i'm making a joke
about it because i probably feel the
opposite of what i just said yeah yeah
you know what i mean because i'm joking
about it yeah but that's why i love
doing podcasts on my patreon like that's
why i i feel like patreon just saves you
know what i mean in a really
a really uh big part of what comedy is
is devil's advocate and defending
something you find reprehensible like as
a comedy exercise being like
i'm pro gold diggers here's what like
it's just like no dude it's where
in a way we're failed lawyers i think in
two like amongst comedians it's like
you can't be hateful and funny it's like
one of the other it's like the people
get in trouble because they're like oh
it's just a joke it's like no you're it
wasn't even remotely funny
we know that it's not funny because your
heart is filled with hate but us it's
like you know we're just like we're just
making jokes because
it's to give relief to the groups you
know but people are like you can't you
can't say that word so it's like
fuck them we stay on the podcast stay in
the patreon patreon.com
christy comedy and just that's where we
live and if true tv
finds a joke from 10 years ago they fire
me good i'll just come back here
fine yeah it's like it's so bulletproof
great it's almost like
that's why i love like the andrew
schultz and the tim hat didn't make a
mistake 10 years ago
it's like yeah it's like even like there
was like a uh in my daughter's school
her teachers
went out um and were like you know bars
are open in new york outdoor
dining they were like they went out and
had a drink during the parent teacher
conference and one of them posted on the
instagram and then they sent
to the teachers uh to the parents could
be like look at our our child's teacher
drinking i'm like she's 25 years old
like
if she wasn't drinking if you were
teaching children all day wouldn't you
need a drink i was like do you know my
kid you know fucking hard
you hung out with your own kids this is
so yeah dude so many of my parents
friends
are sorry about somebody my parents
friends so many of my friends who are
parents yeah
they uh are complaining about they're
like zoom schools so often my kid i'm
like yeah
you're you just had to spend time with
your kid finally yes your kid kicks me
in the shin every time they come your
kids are dickheads
oh my god dude i mean quarantining with
a five-year-old it's like i was
welcoming cole but i was like two weeks
on a ventilator that's a vacation for me
every teacher should get free scotch at
five o'clock yes i was like but these
people are just canceled
crazy it's like shut up also there it is
i think there's a uh
uh a real absence of a
important and kind of boring
conversation about addiction because
these are also people that are addicted
to self-righteous indignation
and we are like there it's cancelled
culture it's also a lot of people that
are
truly addicted to the internet addicted
to the adrenaline they're getting from
this and we're
we a self-righteous indignation is an
addiction like alcohol drugs sex or
anything else
also we have to have compassion for that
as a comic what do you think is a
cancelable offense like what would you
be like
that as a comedian i think anything on
stage or anything that's an attempt of a
joke
to me no matter what it is no matter how
big of a swing you're taking you missed
it's okay it's off the stage stuff if
you do something that's a violation of
our societal rules like you murder
someone you rape someone you do
something like that something illegal
but even that i'm like even like stuff
like that
my whole thing is like like let's say
like the bill cosby thing it's like
why did we i as an as a citizen like why
did i even know what was playing out be
like we have a court of law like
he goes to he goes to the trial he goes
to the court he's he's judged by a jury
of his peers and then he goes and does
the appropriate sentence
why is all everything this trial by
twitter bullshit is very very very
dangerous and scary but it's always
happened it just it happened at water
coolers that happened in people's homes
like
you know and it's it's tricky we've
always had a version of this that's the
other thing we've always had the roman
coliseum
there's a lot of good that comes out of
that yes but there's also like so much
over correction over correction behavior
does have to change but we go
like i think you have to go super far to
come back and there's just going to be
people we ask for change we won't then
we don't allow for the change
but also when we go so far and get
sanctimonious about it
it makes the people that do need to
change not want to learn yes
and so it shuts people down everybody
self-righteous and that's the thing and
what the self-righteousness and the
narcissism comes well
if you know if everybody is a criminal
then nobody's a criminal you know what i
mean if everybody
is is this piece of shit because of x y
and z then we all are it's like
there are people that do bad heinous
things that need to be
tried and removed from our society but i
believe
when they serve their penalty whatever
they are judged
of our peers come up with yeah then they
should be allowed back in society they
have now paid for their crime i feel
like
especially doing this episode that i did
on my podcast the christie chaos podcast
would tell you don't listen to it
yeah if you don't want you don't have to
tt jerry you know was in
jail for 25 years talking to someone
who's like a convict who wants to better
their life
i was like he was like you know i come
out and then i still can't get a job
people still look at me as a criminal
but i paid my 25 years i
you asked me i committed a crime when i
was young and i'm sorry and i stayed in
jail for 25 years so why am i still
treated like
an outcast and i was like that's so true
like anybody who does anything i'm not
saying you have to give them their exact
job back that's you know it's private
citizens whatever but it's like to just
be like oh you're still a fucking piece
of shit get away you can never vote
again it's like those exact people that
need to vote they've been in the
in prison yeah they know about more
outlaws than we do yes
absolutely and according to tt jerry
they all love donald trump so we need
their votes for 2024.
and like it's just um you know i think
the difference there is that when we
cancel celebrities it's like oh you have
so much
right that we don't we don't ever want
to see you again because you're fine
right whereas what you're describing is
like that's terrible yeah yeah
yeah and i think that and and look like
you know it's it's hecklers like i think
you know hecklers they don't know the
damage they're doing and i think a lot
of people on twitter i think a lot of
times they don't know the damage they're
doing
if i may like not to sort of defend
people that are intentionally trying to
ruin people's lives but i also think
like there's this carelessness
especially among
really young people that haven't made
mistakes yet and they don't they don't
understand human flaws they don't
understand you said that dumb thing once
because you were trying to impress
someone and you felt like shit when you
said
like yeah you know i'm saying it's like
half the shit i look back at that i'd
probably cancel i'm like dude no one
was you thought that joke was worse than
like trust me i
i i'm way uh more mad at myself than you
could ever be
they're living in a different world they
have information we never had they've
only lived this way
yes that's true we didn't yeah different
movies different shows different jokes
and they take like one one microcosm of
a person like i mean
160 characters in a person's life to
define them and then you make a judgment
call on that human being it's so
ridiculous i've never gone out of my way
to trash a comedian that i didn't
like like like are an artist or
something it's like the idea of like
i just don't fuck with that person you
know that people are like we need to
cancel this person that
like they're not even fans of they're
just going out of their way to just
throw grenades at people they're not it
used to be you just didn't go to the
show you didn't buy their album you
participate yeah and it's just kind of
like you know like with that whole thing
it's like if you're going to be acting
actively out there trying to cancel
someone then it's like you better be
squeaky clean yourself because that
camera with that spotlight will always
turn back on you
and nobody's perfect nobody i mean good
people do bad things better do good
things i mean
it's just what it is fucking martin
luther king was the greatest person of
all time used to beat the shit out of
his wife
hitler's a horrible person he was a
vegan and loved animals like what do you
want me to tell you
christy comedy.com
you're just hell bent on getting
canceled right now just because it gets
frustratingly annoying sometimes you're
like everybody's a bad person now also
the scale keeps moving
yeah two years we could be like what
something we thought was correct now
yeah yeah just be wrong
just be wrong by the way we're allowed
to be wrong it's like canceling john
wayne like what are we what are we like
oh god
everyone knows he's an asshole like i
don't think anyone like
does your grandmother's john wayne
poster on her wall bother you so much
they went after john wayne from being
like racist or whatever and it was like
of course
he was racist my grandfather said racism
i get like taking down statues because
you don't want to you know memorialize
things but it's like you can't erase
history like my daughter i will tell my
daughter why the confederacy happened i
will tell her why nazism happens
so you don't repeat it but but now i
feel like this whole movement where it's
like so she doesn't
just erase it because she would she
would your daughter oh you would
100 absolutely i gave her an iron cross
for her
birthday i had it signed um
no i'm just like so that to me and as
comedians we're just like you know
what we do and i'm just like man like
these people because because
the irony of it is is when you go into a
room like for online when
you're not in cyberspace you're not on
the internet when you go into the room
and it's all different people of races
religions they're all just laughing in
unison so you're like
is it was it a problem or is it just a
problem in cyberspace in this one realm
but the cyberspace realm has
implications in reality so sometimes
it gets dangerous where you're like wait
the person who's tweeting trying to get
so-and-so canceled
probably doesn't even care about what
they did they're just narcissists they
just want the power for themselves
but they go on the water cooler the next
morning probably have the exact opposite
views
but that person's life got fucked up in
real life totally you know what i mean
but
i will say about comedians as someone
that just brought this conversation up
i love it there is a point where we do
have to stop giving it like we're
professional complainers and we
when we we're the ones that have blown
this out of proportion oh no no yeah so
my thing is like we complain about hot
pockets like comedians will complain
about anything
yeah and so some like there'll be a
couple tweets
quote cancelling someone and then we'll
make it yes we'll talk about in every
podcast every podcast
we'll retweet it and it would have
probably just gone away
had we not exhausted it always goes away
and now you don't it's you don't
really at least in our field you don't
get cancelled by you know evian water or
some company you get cancelled by other
comedians now it's other comedians going
out there and being like
fuck you fuck you fuck you by the way it
never happened when we were seeing each
other every night at comedy club
now that everyone is is at home they're
just throwing each other under the bus
like we used to
have to you know it's been interesting
to see that like everybody can like turn
on
dude i think most of that stuff is like
i think half the time we're fighting
with someone on twitter too it's not
even real people dude i believe 95
of them are russian bots i believe it's
other countries trying to
cause diversion and the fact that we're
responding to it is just like
so silly i feel like sergey in moscow
just laughs his ass off he's like he
think really real
also people are allowed to be upset like
that's the other thing if you're upset
about that joke like
you're allowed to crazy don't come to
the show anymore unfollow i don't know
where your childhood was i might have
walked into shit and triggered you i
mean
jim jeffries got knocked out on stage
when he made a joke about suicide
because some in the audience's brother
had just committed suicide like
we don't know what okay we're walking
into we don't know what stage of healing
you're at like
but it's also it's like i think it's
also clean jobs to adjust with the time
so it does kind of make you a better
comic yes absolutely kind of like
shift into new and new things i agree
with that because we can't keep being
like
oh well in the in the 50s we made jokes
that we have we don't live in the 50s
but also i've seen it and that's the
audience is his job to stop laughing at
shit that isn't funny
we need to grow and certain shit just
isn't funny the way it used to be like
you know because there are some comics
that are like well how come i can't
you're like well because you just can't
now
you just can't no but also it's not
funny first jim saying right it's also
just like so this comedian went out uh
once i was at the comedy store i think
i've told this story
i just think it's important uh came out
this was me like two years ago and
started doing jokes about fat chicks
okay and it was like bombing and then a
woman just went hey can you stop
i've seen the same comedian do that same
joke in nashville and the same thing
happened
wow so there's a point where the
audience will decide the people
not at the show don't need to decide
yeah the people at the show who saw the
context
who saw the crowd not like right that's
that to me is like
right now you need a course correct
because that's not right it's not
working but that person doesn't deserve
to lose their career over it
you know what i mean unless they're
going to double down on it but there's
other comedians who like want to fight
you
but this is yeah which is ridiculous not
new there's always been consequences
yeah and like you know a couple hundred
years ago if you're a woman you just get
killed i mean there's certain things
you know so i it is an interesting thing
and also
i think comedians also need to remember
i said this before is that the more
stuff that's off limits in taboo the
funnier we get
oh my god yeah he gets harder and harder
and harder and then it starts to weed
out people
like you really got to be good now you
know what i mean you really got to be
funny because
if the ones who are just on the border
it's like they'll lose their whole
career so let it we'll keep taking
like there is a way to take risks uh uh
well-intentioned
risks when you're trying to figure out
if something is sure and then you might
go we've done this before i'll go down a
road and i'm like
this is a this is this line of thinking
is not conducive to a hobby that's the
whole art of being a comedian is i have
to try to say we all have to try to say
that thing that we're not supposed to
say crafted in a way in our artful way
that's making everybody laugh and feel
comfortable where we're like stepping to
the line or
slightly over it but we have the joke
that left turn whereas a lot of times
people
will just tweet something like it was
just a joke it's like no you just
tweeted a slur with exclamation points
in the american flag yeah so is it my
thing
worse is the mob mentality because the
mom and daddy can start to make you feel
like oh am i a bad person
then you start to like switch that's
biologically wired into your brain which
is why it is to get the approval of the
tribe
and to get and also is commit the reason
public speaking makes people so nervous
is because uh
on a reptilian primordial level that
meant in tribal times that you were
making your case to the tribe you're
right
you know there's a very yeah you're on
trial completely so this that madness of
crowds book is really good that explains
this mob mentality of like
a lot of people when people go yeah fuck
him
they feel safer when they do that right
so it's we have to recognize that we are
wired to do this we get dopamine when we
gang
up on something else because we think
we're safe yeah well that's why
comedians
that's the worst part it's like other
comedians doing it and that's when it
gets really scary
well that's that shot because then it's
just like yeah like
and comedians there's a lot of if you
fail i win which is not true
it's like the new competition if you get
canceled i have another job oh no
there's some people that me when the
crystal lea thing happened a lot of
female comics
i know and i've seen the screen grabs
who thought that i wouldn't fucking find
out that they were talking to
journalists trying to throw me under the
bus
right because they thought i they would
move up in the it's not how it works
right you know what i'm saying but
that's why it's good that we all you
know or or
you know people need to have something
outside of comedy and entertainment like
you know whatever it is like you have
your project
and i have my family where it's just
like because it the shit just goes away
where i'm just like
ugh all right i'll just i'll again i'll
just push my kid in a swing and then it
goes away i'm not going to sit here all
day
social media i understand we're used to
feedback yes like we're and i think
that's part of the reason they sort of
and we will engage with it a lot of
people won't like a lot of people just
will not respond and ignore it like
that's the real problem
most comedians are comedians because
they were bullied or picked on or
something so now when you have
when you have confrontation why have to
let's go like i don't get to do this in
my relationships anymore i don't get to
get in fights with people like i've been
in recovery like but this is if you
come for me and give me a legitimate
reason to defend myself like i'm fucking
like
because you're kind of like well now i
have fans of people want to see me and i
need some darkness i don't want to go in
the ring like give me any opportunity to
fight you but then
if you're going to come for a comedian
get ready yeah
you're coming for a comedian who's going
to screen grab your profile and fucking
post you yeah they're coming back
yeah yeah we're going to come back we're
not scared of confrontation we're not
and if you
if you try to publicly humiliate one of
us like i feel like we've been pretty
cool about it
yeah you know i feel like most people
have been pretty cool about it because
if you fight back you're the bully
because you're
yeah no i don't respond to i mean you
know it's like the things that people
say
you know it's like every day i get a dm
because somebody calling me a negative
name i don't care dude
where people are go fuck you you're not
funny you went out of your way to dm me
and say that dude
i've already accomplished all my dreams
that someone knows me enough to even
dislike me
yes don't you love that you're not funny
well there's a list of people you can
click on that follow me there's a full
list
of things i'm funny yeah exactly and all
but also like you love me
you're obsessed if you leave any comment
you're obsessed with me you love me
and you're just having a bad day and you
want my you're pulling my pigtails like
i i negative comments to me is like i
look back when i was like 15 in all my
dreams and if someone told me hey
you're going to be so in the public eye
as a comedian that people are going to
be saying you're
going to be like dude sign me up but
think about that even what we're going
back to before think about a person
think about what state of your life you
have to be in or what kind of person you
have to be to comment negatively
publicly on anything
as my therapist would say it sounds like
they're in a lot of pain yes i
left a negative comment or anything i
wouldn't i've never in my life left
left a negative comment on anything i've
never left a negative yelp review i've
never done any of that because i'm like
i will just move on with my life this
thing didn't work for me but we have big
voices and big platforms not everybody
does
yeah you know what i'm saying some i'm
just saying it makes people feel well
get on stage
i'm not saying it's good i'm saying it i
know never my whole life have i done
but i know why people do it it's b they
feel they're
they're hurting they're in pain like you
know or they're mean and and nasty
people and they have to live their lives
and we get to do this you know
most people just want attention back
from the person yeah but even even when
i announced yeah always when someone
says you're an old nasty busted cunt and
i'm like hey dude i hope that worked
it's usually what i'll write really
great
i didn't know you'd see that always
becomes a conversation
yeah it's people have a sickness bless
your heart you know yeah
like we need to stop complaining about
negative comment it's so
um uh childish of us because our
comedian's whole thing is
we should be able to over the fuck we
want but you can't yeah
yeah i'm saying it's like pick a lane we
have to decide one or the other because
we're like i want to say whatever the
fuck i want
the fucking picker and but you're not
allowed
to say anything negative about me but
i'm allowed to say anything negative
about anyone i want
publicly you know so it's like that
sounds reasonable to me
what's the problem yeah it's a problem
as a fan i think that sounds great yeah
um
all you need to shut the fuck up um
because that is really what we do we go
into a room and say no one's allowed to
speak if you speak security's gonna
remove you we are
fucking brats i know i know i know i
know this whole podcast we've been like
saying like everyone's a narcissist like
we're the ones that go on stage and be
like sit down and listen to me i have
the microphone literally out of the
thousand people here i am the most
not only that i'm gonna charge you yeah
sixty dollars to listen to me speak for
an hour
yeah what's that to yeah complain yeah
about luxuries yeah yeah about how good
it gets
and then when you say something not
gonna go thank you yeah you just paid 50
for me to read out of a notebook because
i didn't want to even prepare for myself
you just
you're looking at your tickets you're
like yeah i was like 60 you're like 15.
50. yeah yeah i'm almost at 60. but now
yeah 48.
we asked you to like order shitty food
we asked you to get a babysitter to find
parking for me to be like
so what else is happening yeah yeah yeah
guys what what are you up to for me to
do crowdsourcing to ask you where you're
from in your own state yeah we
immediately
say from here to find out if there's any
birthdays in the crowd and then you
immediately make fun of where they're
from i hate this place
hated driving here hate the club yeah
you to come watch you trash their city
oh god i mean
it's like we are such we are to be
killed
and then we're just giving everyone i
mean we should we are awful awful people
what can you do um but yeah but i wish
people um just in general comedians like
just
we're not trying to be your heroes i
don't know why people started thinking
comedians or the people you like look up
to
yeah why am i being held to the same
standard as a politician i'm just a
comedian
fucking doing tweeting jokes from my
bathroom like why are you taking me
you're in don't know how to end the
podcast um i just have the producers
zoom in on my open asshole
that's what i pitched yes but i don't
know how to use this yeah i don't do it
anymore because i have warts
anal warts do you shave your balls
manscape.com
um lawnmower 3.0 um everyone has the
fucking sponsorship
i know i'm just curious okay i i uh i do
you i do this is this is less
what's going on that is so hard because
when what my girl
you know if you shave your balls it's
like why are you shoving balls for all
you're trying to look good for
so i don't do it as much but i did just
recently i did just recently shave my
balls yes uh-huh yes and it was good and
but you have to i'm so fascinated
by how guys do it because you have to
put your foot up on a
like i feel like you have to put your
foot up and you gotta like no
hold it and pull in no do you know what
i do you know what i do i figured out
the secret at least for me it works for
me is i actually tuck it back i give
myself a man giant it's easier to shave
my man pussy
than it is my dick and balls so i go old
so i go i go buffalo bill i buffalo
billet and i shave
yes such a great round yes and then i
let it fly back and then i you know
shave my
the hairs floating off my actual
testicles and then i do it all in the
shower
and you know i get some of it on my
daughter's barbies and whatever you just
clean that off
my daughter's barbies are transgendered
because of my beautiful
your barbies have a little mustache yeah
that's why because it's
it's inclusive i have an inclusive
barbie for my daughter i think we
figured out the best way to end these
now we just asked yeah for our tutorials
i'm obsessed with that because yeah i
think i don't like them if you're going
to do it
are they i get waxed i've never the ball
no i get one does that hurt
interesting well i have like the harm
over most places so yeah
yeah the ball because i used to do the
waxing torture there's like buildings
you got like
and it's so fast i've been waxed and
it hurt like all hell and then the only
reason
that i like didn't start crying is she
was like you should see guys when they
get their balls waxed
i went in for my move to new york first
time big city girl went in to get my
eyebrows waxed but they had me take my
uh
take my pants off so i was like oh i
guess this is your eyebrows i guess it's
just what they do in new york
and then she gave me a full brazilian
i was screaming so loud and the woman
was doing it within chemo treatments she
was and she was like you're
a sucker pussy and i was crying and i
was like how can anyone stand this
she's like it's not as bad what are they
doing to you and so i've never done it
since and i can do that
on all fours no oh they do that do i go
to the wrong place
wait what sammy's like i have had a full
bush since then i will not let anybody
go
the wind was whistling through my jeans
wait you guys can you guys
you guys yeah when they went to your bus
you guys benton's been sexually
assaulted and he's coming forward
that's what they do you know all four
how do they get to it
never happens how do you get on all
fours to wax your asshole yeah what was
this company i'm calling them right now
and doing them
it's an aesthetician that is my friend
oh she's really nice her name is
candy i've i've got a qualm with you a
bitch i just got a text
said you were going to be home by 3 30
then send me the voicemail at four with
a thumbs up
i'm so excited okay i am so fucked up
don't write elephants sounds like you
really need to go it's just what we can
wrap up it's one of those things when
you get a text like that
i'm fucked already like it's i'm done it
happened with david yellow too
my wife you i just went to a girl's name
whitney's house for seven hours
yeah it's i'm in trouble i got it it's
recorded so she knows our podcasts are
long
yeah i don't know who that is
and i don't know that not a fan um okay
i love you this has been like a fucking
blast and um your podcast uh
uh i got hey babe with salvagana what
you do that's a fully squeaky clean show
which is hard to do we try to
we don't curse that's so interesting and
we do it on purpose because we're like
this is a sick challenge to try to do
and then chrissy chaos is the other
podcast i have
that's my own solo podcast and i have
guests sometime where we go the opposite
and i interviewed jasmine's uh relatives
who just got out of prison
it was very good so that's funny we have
fun and i've patreon patreon.com christy
comedy
where i really get fucking wild i'll
shave my balls for the 10 deer
what is it ten dollars i got five and
ten i just make it simple
five and ten and then you put videos i
put video i do no no i do
exclusive episodes that only air on
patreon wow like i won't ever release
them on youtube or any so i do a full
hour extra each week just for the
patreon members from my family
christians for comedians that were could
never work again but this is this is the
application no i feel like i want to i
want to i want to be in all of it i want
to be on tv
podcast patreon do it all why the fuck
not i love you model mayhem only fans
because patreon you don't have to worry
about
you just put it out there you just put
it out there you just relax
yeah it's just great and then i feel
like the funniest stuff happens or some
of the funny stuff i think
that i could do yeah you're not worried
and the fans just respond it's great i
love you
um we're releasing you i'm just i'm
literally just sweating
too much like i'm just my breath
literally smells like jelly bean shit
like i could smell my breath off the mic
i'm like wow this is bad
it is so fucking gross okay i love you
um
uh i love you um do we have
announcements no
no no okay
[Music]
four four four six
you